dave chappelle has fired back at the
activists and the netflix employees that
were complaining about his comedy
special with his own list of demands he
said i will not bend to anyone but if
you want to meet you have to abide by my
conditions and one of them was a direct
roast of comedian hannah gadsby and he
said
he just said you have to admit she's not
funny and it's just uh it's kind of
funny dave chappelle's basically
striking back rejecting the cancellation
of him as a comedian but this is an
interesting subject because i'm not
entirely sure dave chappelle will
survive the cancel attempt because these
activists jump in front of the building
as you may have seen with this big
protest they attack people the media
lies on their behalf and it goes viral
but i gotta say dave chappelle's
response right now might actually be
what helps fend this off because he's
refusing to back down in such a way
maybe we'll get something out of it we
got to talk about that and i want to
talk about cnn's ratings being just
absolutely miserable the ratings for joe
biden's town hall were in the gutter
and then we have arrested voucher
trending because fauci was in funding
some very disturbing animal experiments
and now people want him to be arrested
so we'll talk about that we'll talk
about a lot there's a lot going on cops
quitting cops protesting in new york
marching down the street chanting let's
go brandon we've got san francisco
prosecutors quitting people in sf saying
you can't live here anymore it's too
dangerous
so
joining us to talk about all of this is
mark hemingway you want to introduce
yourself yeah hi i'm mark hemingway uh i
am a senior writer for real clear
investigations and
i have worked at three magazines two
daily newspapers a financial wire
service and a think tank over the course
of my career and uh yeah so i'm glad to
be here at the future of journalism oh
wow thank you there's a book behind you
yes
uh so i co-wrote this book with my wife
uh behind me uh it's on the uh 2020
election it's called rigged
uh i'm gonna have to turn around to
remember the subtitle
how the media big tech and democrats
seized our elections uh and uh so this
book was kind of an attempt to make
sense of what happened in 2020 um where
you know there was a lot of crazy you
know things that people were saying
about what happened or did happen after
the election but the truth is you know
my wife and i stepped back and took like
you know 30 000 foot view of the
election where you have big tech
censorship you have all these crazy
coveted narratives um you know you have
rule changes yeah state level there were
massive changes across the board to
election rules because the pandemic and
everything else mail in balloting being
this you know massive thing that
happened um and really looked at how the
election happened and i mean i i think
we we you know came to the conclusion i
think a lot of people do it felt very
uneasy about the election which is to
say that you know i'm not out here
saying the election was stolen but was
it a situation here where people would
say it was free and fair and wasn't like
substantially corrupt i don't think so
easy way to put it is time magazine's
the shadow campaign to save the election
we talk a lot about that in the book i
mean they literally called a coalition
of corporate interests coming together
to oust donald trump a cabal in time
magazine and somehow this wasn't setting
off klaxons you guys are crazy
conspiracy theorists they were just
fortifying it all right
welcome back beautiful and amazing human
beings this is okadowski here of we are
change.org and we just had an incredible
event just a few hours ago here in west
virginia it was awesome i remember going
on stage and i don't know what happened
but something happened where i just was
speaking my mind and i was just i was
like wait wait wait wait hold on i don't
want to take over this event
but it was really incredible it was
really awesome and i was so happy to be
a part of it and thanks thank you guys
for organizing it and oh yeah the shirt
i have on will either get you instant
friends or enemies and it says
the media is the virus and you could get
yours on the best political shirts.com
it was invigorating to be eight feet
away from you when you lit fire like a
lightning rod on stage the other night i
don't know what happened it was just
like ah spirit embodies
a lightning rod that's right i'm part
slavic too i think deep down hey i'm
actually just looking at rogan's
instagram and i see him chappelle
donnell tom segura and uh jeff ross
played in nashville i think i think
dave's gonna be okay he's got a good
group of friends
and gonna keep him grounded and keep him
because really it's famous you can be
famous as you want you can still go
crazy but when you have good friends
that's what you need
and that's what he's got absolutely i'm
glad to be here as well um our event was
fantastic i wish that more people could
have come i'm hoping that we can expand
as we go along what we need to get our
chops and see if we can make everything
work perfectly for everyone
right on before we get to the news my
friends how to head over to timcast.com
become a member we're gonna have a
members-only segment coming up around 11
or so p.m and you'll be supporting our
fierce and independent journalists as
you can see right here in the member
content for the green room show which
fridays we got behind the scenes with
viva fry and robert barnes
i definitely want to check that out it's
just fun hanging out it's not super
heavy political stuff you know you can
see us so we're chilling look how happy
we are just chilling there in the green
room if you want to be if you want to
check that out become a member and don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends let's talk about some news and i
want to i want to start with dave
chappelle because
you know i was talking about the alec
baldwin incident earlier
uh i believe new information has emerged
showing that alec baldwin is potentially
criminally responsible for this and i'm
not trying to make this a segment about
alec baldwin but i want to explain
this is a guy
who is the producer in a movie
who knew there had been a neglig
negligent discharge multiple times
was then handed a weapon did not check
it even though he's been trained for
decades pointed it at the crew pulled
the trigger killing a woman and you see
all these people on the left saying he's
not at fault it was an accident there
was a post on reddit where they were
like if you think that a guy who
accidentally shot someone should go to
jail but the president shouldn't you
know donald trump then they're like yeah
something's wrong with you and i'm like
let me just say one more time
alec baldwin was a producer on the movie
there had been two separate negligent
discharges the crew knew about some
crude walked off the set he has been
trained in how to handle the firearms on
different movies and he didn't which
means there's there's got to be a
criminal investigation into what he knew
and what he didn't now i bring that up
because it's purely cultural the
politics don't matter
alec baldwin is an activist right so
everyone's like oh you know alec baldwin
we've got to protect him that's really
what it's about so when i see the story
with dave chappelle not a tran uh to
segue into why why the dave chappelle
story matters i actually was saying in
the past week or so with this whole dave
chappelle netflix thing you get the
netflix employees coming out physically
attacking a guy claiming that after they
destroy his sign claim it's now a weapon
then the media reports that the guy was
actually the one attacking them
culture is everything and they've got
the media they've got cultural
institutions but dave chippell did
something funny variety says dave
chappelle willing to discuss the closer
with trans community but says he's not
bending to anybody's demands this is not
true dave chappelle actually says
members of the lgbtq plus and trans
community were supportive of him these
are the activists these are the wingnut
activists the political actors
not people who are simply lgbtq and he
said quote
i want everyone in this audience to know
that even though the media frames it
that it's me versus that community
that is not what it is do not blame the
lgbtq community for any of this crap
this is nothing to do with them it's
about corporate interests and what i can
say and what i cannot say for the record
and i need you to know this everyone i
know from that community has been loving
and supportive supporting so i don't
know what all this nonsense is about
he said i believe his uh chappelle also
spoke about the upcoming documentary
this film that i made was in uh was
invited to every film festival in the
united states and some of those
invitations i accepted when this
controversy came out about the closer
they began disinviting me from these
film festivals and now today not a film
company not a movie studio not a film
festival nobody will touch this film
thank god for ted sarandos and netflix
he's the only one that didn't cancel me
yet this is this is important context
people did not realize that dave
chappelle has been canceled across the
board but he's standing defiant
they going to say though chappelle said
he was willing to meet with some members
of the trans community
or the activist community see how they
try to do that with variety they try to
make make these these these extremists
the entirety of the trans community i'm
pretty sure blair white's a member of
that community we had a fan at the event
saturday who was trans this is not fair
he says he jokingly jokingly jokingly
listed off a slew of conditions that
would have to be met quote to the
transgender community i am more than
willing to give you an audience but you
will not summon me i'm not bending to
anybody's demands and if you want to
meet with me i'd be more than willing to
but i have some conditions first of all
you cannot come if you have not watched
my special from beginning to end nice
you must come to a place of my choosing
at a time of my choosing and thirdly you
must admit that hannah gadsby is not
funny
there was brilliant smart i loved it and
that was the perfect response we needed
right now there's a huge conflict
happening and we also have to understand
that this is not just dave chappelle
shooting shots for no reason this hannah
gatsby attacked dave and the ceo of
netflix before
the ceo of netflix came out in response
to a lot of this controversy by saying
quote so we have sex education orange is
the new black control z hannah gadsby
and dave chappelle all on netflix key to
this is increasing diversity on the
content team itself now that's a simple
response saying hey everyone here
gets a voice on this platform on this
very important platform and hannah
responded on instagram
by saying quote ted just a quick note to
let you know that i would prefer if you
didn't drag my name into your mess now i
have to deal with even more of the hate
and anger that dave chappelle's fans
like to unleash on me every time dave
gets 20 million dollars to process his
emotions stunned partial world views and
then later she adds you didn't pay me
nearly enough to deal with this with the
real world consequences of the hate
speech whistling you refuse to
acknowledge f you ted your and your
amoral algorithm cult so those are very
big words by her yeah
well i think a lot of people are angry
at uh gatsby for you know continuing the
marketing market what she does is comedy
i mean that would induce some kind of
hateful response in me if i was told
this was going to be funny and i watched
what she did
but you know you've made a really
excellent point there though about how
they keep trying to say that this
activist fringe represents this wide
swath of people i saw andrew sullivan
speak just a couple of weeks ago and he
made this point where he said you know
it's been crazy you know i'm a gay man
you know my historical civil rights
struggle and whatever else there is
about my identity is not the same as a
lesbian it's not the same as a bisexual
it's not the same as a transsexual and
with q they're just including every
white woman with blue hair right um i
mean i it's absolutely insane that
somehow you can claim to speak for so
many people and everyone just accept
that as a fact i'll say this i'll take
credit for being at least somewhat right
in this regard because i was saying when
this is starting i think dave chappelle
is going to lose this one i tweeted lol
they're trying to cancel dave chappelle
and i think it and i said actually i
think it might work
to hear dave come out and say that he's
being disinvited from film festivals and
no one will touch this film anymore they
got him
i yeah no i i i think you're right
talking about the closer yeah i'm pretty
sure he's talking about the closer
oh closer the closer well
man no
netflix owns it it's licensed yeah but
he's saying he he says the film i made
was invited to every film festival in
the u.s
when the controversy came out he got
disinvited from all of these film
festivals it was only netflix that were
willing to take him i think this only
happened because he opened up that
possibility by ending the comedy special
seriously and i think if he would have
laughed it off i think it would have
been like sticks and stones that's just
my own personal opinion on this matter
but again as you see hannah gatsby
responds very seriously the best way to
disarm someone who's too serious and
taking themselves way too seriously is
to laugh at them so this was the perfect
response to hannah and and you know a
lot of people are laughing about this a
lot of people are talking about this
this is this is something that is could
go either way but the shots were fired
back by dave it was good to see those
shots fired so i also want to say i
think people make a mistake in thinking
that this is somehow about the audience
i mean this is really about what's going
on internally at all of these
entertainment companies
a couple months back i did a story on
digital advertising and how there are
all these boycotts against you know you
know right-leaning media and stuff like
that and the guy you know i talked to an
advertising exec and and he made this
point you know explicitly said it used
to be when this stuff first started
happening you could go to the company
and you'd say look this is just a social
media focus it's going to blow over in
48 hours you've got nothing to worry
about now it's totally different the
culture has penetrated these companies
so what you've got to worry about is
like you know sarandos and netflix or
whatever dealing with his you know top
10 10 of his top executives coming to
him saying you know i'm not going to
work at this company if you continue to
act this way because they're all look
that's the that's the firearm
yeah they got to fire these people well
they also have to deal with the esg and
a lot of the big banks and a lot of the
big institutions that are pushing
pressure on them so it's not just
netflix and the employees there i mean
and even with that protest i mean did
you see how the media hyped it up a
thousand people are gonna come out maybe
a few dozen let's be honest here i think
that was actually fair uh so i saw the
criticism that there was like one source
that said
we estimate a thousand people will come
the media ran it and then everyone
picked the story up but as you know luke
whenever you see a a a like a a social
media post saying like come to this
event and there are invites given up on
facebook when it says a thousand we
always would be like that means a
hundred yeah for sure because you get
ten times as many people saying they
will go and a tenth show
but but this is also important to bring
up because they had the mainstream media
hyping this up so people were hearing
about this people knew about this far
and wide they were doing showed up
exactly i mean when you compare that you
we also have to understand that on the
bigger backdrop of it that that they got
a lot of promotion for this and if you
have that much promotion you would
expect a bigger protest from my own
personal perspective but again that just
proves that i was saying this is not
about what audiences want out of comedy
this is about the imperatives of
corporations that's what this is about i
think that you know
dave chappelle is
it's like a grandfathering and kind of
thing where when dave chappelle's career
ends
when he gets old and moves on we will
never see a dave chappelle
for this this new time period so i'll
put it this way assuming that
you know what let me slow down
michael malus likes to say you know
these people are so dumb how could you
possibly think we're going to lose and
i'm like dude zombies are dumb too
but a lot of them overwhelm the system
and then people are running at least in
movies if dave chappelle is saying there
that festivals are canceling him and
he's the king
joe rogan said he's possibly the
funniest guy the funniest comedian in
the planet
then then what does that mean for where
we're headed so what happens now is you
know i was actually thinking that dave
chappelle might survive this he might
survive the cancellation to a certain
degree
and then what would happen is they would
just be like
let him age out once he's no longer in
media or relevant we just don't the next
generation do it so there was that guy
shane what's his name what the guy from
snl who was like he got fired oh yeah
members last night gillis
shane mcgillis
check that out so this is a really good
example shane gillis did an asian accent
stereotype you remember the story yeah i
do and then he got fired
uh a chappelle on netflix did the same
did a even more egregious where he like
made the face and everything and it was
celebrated they cheered for it they even
gave him another special at you know 20
plus million dollars
so so i for a while i thought okay
they're going to not let any of the new
guys any new people with this kind of
humor edgy humor get jobs and they'll
tolerate the old comedians until they're
finally gone now it's like they're even
nuking chappelle now you know so i'm not
i'm not i don't want to be
i think people need to realize
if the story ended there fine i guess
you'd call that pessimistic i'm not
saying the story ends there i'm saying
we're doing stuff we had an event with
ryan long i can't say what ryan long
said hilarious he's awesome but it was
insane everyone was like
ryan long is an amazing comedian and
then he was like he it was i i don't i
can't spoil any of the jokes but it was
extremely offensive you had people going
like oh man but it was hilarious
and you're not gonna find that on
netflix no you're not going to find that
but i do think things are happening like
so like vaclav havel in czechoslovakia
you know he wrote this famous essay
where he talked about the creation of a
parallel polis
meaning that you know when you live in a
culture that is so you know dominated by
lies that it's necessary for the people
that don't want to live to by those lies
to like create you know their own
institutions in their own culture and
live by that now the crazy thing about
this what's happening is they're
foisting all this stuff on us from the
top down right but at the same time
we're not communist czechoslovakia you
know i mean you know maybe you know it's
not dark yet it's getting there but um
we still live in a culture where we can
build our own institutions we can do new
things like you know this show for
instance we can build up a parallel
polish and maybe if we do enough of that
then we can supplant this sort of you
know dominant ideology yeah definitely
especially with the way psychedelics
break people out of that crap i think
that and they're like in dc now they're
they've decriminalized psilocybin i
think pretty much uh washington state
like that will
shatter this nonsense maybe there's a
lot of people who live in this matrix
you know but i want to say something i
want to say i i was enlightened today
when my name was trending on twitter
and uh it was also trending alongside
noam chomsky
for one reason
dune
the new movie you saw it uh i saw half
of it
because we walked out of the theater
um i will say this and i'm trying to be
offensive so get ready to be offended
dune fans
the only people who like dune are the
originalists who are fans of the book
they understand what they're watching
and they're amazed and inspired by the
cinematography the art it was beautiful
the music was amazing incredible and
robots that were made to be on the
internet to prop up the movie and try
and help sell it but i genuinely think
they're trying to you know we talked
about this after we walked out i think i
think they're trying to tank the movie
because they released it for free on hbo
max and the theater was empty but i i'm
i i was going to say
you know i'm trending on twitter and i'm
like this is why there's going to be a
civil war not seriously about doom but
we walked into the theater i said the
movie was too slow there was no story in
the hour we watched it was confusing and
nothing was happening to the hardcore
dude fans they totally understood it we
walked out but to see the amount of hate
that was generated by this
and a ton of the tweets were basically
like
they were political the the leftist dune
fans were attacking me over politics for
me saying i didn't enjoy a movie and i'm
like we are absolutely effed
if if if we're like at a point where
these leftists are all sharing my tweet
my name was trending because leftists
were
quoting me and sharing it around i had
high profile youtubers on the left that
was their big attack
that was it not not a policy position
because what what what what do i tweet
about where they're going to be like
something i disagree with
i look at things like that
which you know in turn like the alec
baldwin thing that's why i think culture
is the most important thing
otherwise or i should say
what's happening is that
there are there are people like noam
chomsky and we'll we'll we'll start
talking about noam chomsky in a minute
who think that they own all culture the
entire country and that they are the
dominant force with supreme power
and then there are people who realize
that's not true and these people are
moral absolutist and authoritarians but
i wonder you know if people if any of
those people will will realize that they
don't have the majorities they think
they do
i think sometimes we might be too hard
on ourselves and i think we should
celebrate some victories especially when
it comes to alternatives whether it's
this show
rogan and others we have to understand
even with all the odds against us even
with the algorithms even with the
demonetizations the down rankings and
the controlling of the algorithm still
our voices are heard and i think that's
a victory in itself but even if they do
cancel dave at these festivals these
festivals are missing out on a real
discussion that people really want to
have about these issues that is honest
that isn't censored that isn't squeezy
cleaned that isn't people lecturing them
about what they think is right so i
think these voices will always be heard
in one way or another and it's it's a
good thing
we did this event on saturday we had a
bunch of people come out and someone
asked me about joe rogan and they said
they felt like joe rogan was letting us
down in terms of the culture war and
standing up for freedom and stuff you
know and i basically was like dude joe
rogan has done more for freedom than you
know almost anyone else and it's he's an
incredibly powerful voice in media that
you know we're grateful to have but
i will say you know i was disappointed
that he performed at madison square
garden over the vax mandate he says he's
against it but here we go and then we
were actually just talking before the
show about cn about cnn with sanjay
gupta and then michael malus
we were talking about how
you know uh rogan called don lemon a
dumb mother effer
yep and then cnn tripled down but you
were you're you're mentioning to us
about how he was defending cnn even yeah
i mean joe rogan clearly has a personal
relationship with jeff zucker who runs
cnn uh but before he ran cnn he was he
headed up nbc when joe rogan was was you
know doing fear factor over there and
you know on one hand i respect that you
know joe rogan has a personal
relationship with somebody doesn't
immediately want to like throw them
under the bus but on the other hand
i don't know what to say i mean he was
saying lots of things along the lines of
you know well media are important you
know we've got to you know work with
these you know people we've got to deal
with this
and it was just like completely
conflicting like on one hand they have
literally just personally attacked him
slandered him on air i've said things
that were patently untrue about what he
did um you know i mean the ivermectin
thing was insane i mean the guy also
took monoclonal antibodies which is like
the standard medical therapeutic
why does why doesn't he why doesn't he
sue
well that's a really good question i
mean i we really need more people that
can stand up and challenge media
organizations in ways that it's going to
make them hurt uh i've written a lot
about this before where you know the
media in this america have you know
amazing libel protections um it's very
hard to sue a media company especially
if you're a
public figure and you know do anything
with that um and for a long time i think
that was a source of pride in this
country you know in the uk and other
countries you know there are a lot of
frivolous libel lawsuits but we've kind
of gone to the extreme like i think
maybe 60 years ago there was a big
public interest in protecting large
media organizations they were doing
important you know corruption reporting
and things like that at a time when
there weren't a lot of alternatives to
do media stuff now increasingly you see
things like the covington kid incident
um you know just really capricious mean
stuff
um coming from the media directed by
people clearly for political motivations
where they're using these libel laws uh
as a as a sword rather than a shield i
mean they know they can't be sued or
they know it's gonna be difficult or
costly to sue them so they're just
aggressively going after people in ways
that are brutally unfair you were saying
before that times v sullivan was kind of
assuming that the the media
organizations were going to be ethical
and maintain that and which was always
kind of a bad assumption but it was a
much better assumption 60 years ago than
it is now when clearly they just aren't
i mean if you see what goes on uh you
know in cnn or any frankly major news
organization where the new york times
editorial staff literally says words or
violence i mean that is not a regime
that we can prop up you know under the
color of you know law um you know that
needs to ordinary citizens need and and
even public figures like joe rogan need
to have an
opportunity to go after these people and
stop them from doing that stuff again
give them an incentive bloody their nose
say don't lie about me again when did
the media become such an obvious
propaganda machine and i don't mean just
i don't mean just politically i mean you
look at rotten tomatoes right the film
death wish with bruce willis
this is a studio phone this is abs
a-listing a-lister hollywood celeb
but death which got panned by critics
because they called it a gun nut
masturbation film right and it wasn't it
was a it was a revenge film like any
other action film but they went nuts on
it and that said to me it's not about
making money
for hollywood it's about making sure
only specific ideologies get the
promotion from the machine i think it's
jon stewart jack posobik said this on
the show last week that jon stewart
basically weaponized comedy and politics
and combined them and i was like i love
jon stewart it hurt to hear that but
before that it didn't exist and after
that it started to we also have to admit
that this is their greatest weapon but
it's also their their greatest weakness
because the more disingenuous the more
they lie the more they just make stuff
up and attack
children or or grandmothers who meme at
their door and try to dox them like cnn
did the more they just become more and
more outrageous the more people realize
hey this is this is getting to a really
sick level and we need some alternatives
here immediately and they will turn to
alternatives the onion kind of started
at two the when people saw how popular
it was to just say things that were
patently false and like put a little
disclaimer at the bottom be like by the
way this is all a joke
it was
dangerous you know dangerous yeah i
think for a long time you know we had a
healthier culture in the sense that
there was kind of a cultural realm and
there was a political realm and there
was a little bit of overlap as there
always was but by and large those things
were kept separate and i you know i
don't know i mean it's sort of the
post-modern influence i think just
everything got crazy meta
like andrew barbara used to say you know
politics is downstream from culture and
that's that's true to a large extent and
there was this kind of like meta
realization across the board that that
was the case so all of a sudden the
narratives in culture literally became
the quote unquote narrative meaning that
they realized they could use that to
control things politically so you know
in the case of dune or something we
can't just talk about how house
harkonnen you know is an interesting
metaphor that might have some salience
for our political situation or whatever
it immediately becomes a you know uh
method of attack for tim simply because
he didn't enjoy a movie you know it's it
everything is political now yeah well it
was funny because breitbart said
politics is downstream from culture then
we started hearing the social justice
activists the woke saying that the the
culture is political
or the cultural is political and then
you have people pushing back saying no
it's not and i'm like it is
i i think we should take breitbart
statement one step further and say
politics does not even matter
the way i explained this before is
uh
here's here's an example you know you
ever see those book wacky laws yeah
there's like
laws from the 1800s where it's like no
apple pies cooling on the windowsill on
tuesday at 7 p.m
never going to be enforced today why
culture the politics the legislation the
laws are completely meaningless
now to a certain extent that's i'm
obviously being a little hyperbolic
if there's something on the books and
we're like i disagree with this law and
then they're going to be like yeah well
you know the law is the law and you're
going ah i guess
however over time when culture changes
those laws become completely meaningless
and they can remain in the books and
politicians politicians can say that you
can't do that people do it anyway
so if that's the case then culture is
everything and if we're not advocating
for freedom and liberty and pushing back
against authoritarianism then you will
live in authoritarian woke matrix
and that's where the the the the
democrats the the people who live in
these bubbles the activists screaming at
this guy at the dave chappelle thing
they live in the social credit system
you can choose to live in it or you can
choose to walk away but right now we're
seeing it get bigger and bigger and dave
chappelle has just been flunked out of
the social credit system
yeah i think i think there's a lot of
truth to what you just said um i mean
the whole point of the way the american
political system was set up previously
it was to be a quote unquote limited
government precisely because they
expected everyone to live basically the
full spectrum of their lives in the
cultural sphere
and now
you can't get away
i mean and and that is in and of itself
very much a form of tyranny you know
we're we're basically two separate
cultures demanding each other abide by
the rules of the other and that can't
that is untenable at least two the court
of public opinion is so real they uh and
now that everyone's in public it's like
it's like the evolution of law like like
obviously if beau marche for instance i
don't know if you guys are familiar with
him he's a french revolutionary
basically aided the americans and was
like the number one french guy that
helped she'd be considered one of the
founding fathers he got into legal
trouble but because he was such a
celebrity they just overlooked it let
them out um and that and what we saw
maybe with what we're gonna see with
alec baldwin like what we saw with uh
uh what the guy that kneeled on george
floyd's neck i mean that was public
opinion that was a a court of public
opinion that translates right now so
we'll see what happens so the laws they
write them down on paper but in reality
it's what the people feel and say and do
that matters and we have to add another
layer to this that that is also
manipulated because when you look at
what's promoted highlighted on social
media what's shown to you first it's the
ideas that they want you to believe in
so if they want to make everyone feel
that everyone's outraged about this
specific thing they're only going to be
showing you that on social media to the
point where it actually creates that
situation because everyone's going to
see this is what people are doing i want
to fit in i want to be normal i'm going
to be doing this as well so i would
actually point at big tech social media
as being far more responsible at setting
the culture then of course the
mainstream media less and less people
are watching the mainstream media less
and less people are watching jimmy
fallon and stephen colbert people hate
to be lectured to people hate to be
preached too and that's exactly what the
mainstream media does i mean just a
couple years ago i remember leno and
letterman and and the way i remember
them is that they would make fun of the
democrats and the republicans they would
talk about celebrity gossip nonsense
they would rarely get as political as
the current commentators do now to the
point where we have all these
commentators saying the same thing at
the same time slot with very little
political difference uh because they're
literally preaching establishment uh
bootlicking talking points if we see a
fascist dictatorship over take over it's
gonna be corporate of course yes without
a doubt the corporatocracy the the
multinational corporations they're the
ones essentially here creating not only
the esg score that that we talked about
with jack pasok when he was on the show
this is a very important social credit
score the corporate social credit score
these are the people calling the shots
here and with them calling the shots
they not just they don't just implement
this they create this idea that this is
popular this is what this is public
opinion they shape public opinion by by
pretending that it is reality when in
the beginning phases it's not let's go
with a little bit of good news but also
kind of bad news
and i'll start with a question
uh
joe biden recently appeared on cnn um
mark how many viewers do you think they
attracted to that spectacle with the
president of these united states so
because i'm an insane media junkie i
believe it was 1.42 million 1.42 oh fox
news says 1.2 okay sorry five
were giving you were giving too much to
joe biden i was quoting cnn math yeah
well so here we have the story from fox
news cnn's brian stouter of void's
network's poorly watched biden town hall
and reliable sources media show cnn's
primetime event averaged only 1.2
million viewers finishing in third place
behind fox news and msnbc
think about what this means that doesn't
mean what you think it means
my initial reaction was wow people would
rather watch the daily fox or msnbc as
opposed to the president give a town
hall
man biden must suck
well the better way to put it is people
don't care about biden they would rather
watch their their their cannon fodder
for the culture war
that's that's what's actually important
biden is irrelevant in the culture war
he was not trump therefore he got votes
but right now we're seeing that for one
okay here's the good news cnn is in
crisis you know they can't even get more
than they can they can't even get a
couple million viewers off the president
himself that's also indicative of what's
happening to this country with fox and
msnbc doing better people want the fight
yeah no i think that's absolutely true
but at the same time i mean cnn has
become msnbc i mean that there's no
difference there for a long time in
cable news there was they differentiated
themselves fox was a conservative
network msnbc was a little network and
cnn was they were the liberal media but
they were at least trying to like you
know present themselves as the
acceptable alternative that could be
shown in airports um now i mean they're
they're they're deranged i mean their
prime time network i mean their prime
time programming i mean it's not really
in tone and substance different from
msnbc in terms of their political till
don lemon
may be one of the stupidest people i
have ever
seen hey that cuomo is also on that
network so sure you have to hey hey
you're insulting stupid people now do
you remember when don lemon asked if the
missing malaysian airline may have been
sucked into a black hole i remember that
that's a true story good stuff that's
that that's that's cnn desperate for
ratings
he's like what is it possible i know
it's preposterous but is it preposterous
yes and people are like oh come on tim
he was just having a little bit of fun
and i'm like dude
if you want to speculate on what could
happen to a plane a black hole
swallowing it is the stupidest possible
thing to even joke about because a black
hole wouldn't be able to get anywhere
near the plant without destroying
substantially more than just one
airplane but that's cnn for you these
are the trusted name and news tim i mean
they're the ones that youtube trusts
more than anyone else they're the ones
that they're they get put on the top of
the list they get shown to everyone
so years ago david foster wallace wrote
this really interesting essay about
conservative talk radio for the atlantic
back in the day supposedly wallace was
an interesting guy uh supposedly he was
a big rush limbaugh fan i don't know if
he agreed with limbo's politics but like
he just liked listening to radio
and he made this observation in the in
the piece where he was talking all these
talk radio people about how they would
harp on the same subjects over and over
again
um about how they compared talk radio
and the ideas that the way they talked
about things to
um you know regular radio where it's
like look just because the morning dj
played the hit song doesn't mean that
you as the evening dj don't get to play
the hit song everybody wants to hear the
hit song and i think cable news has
carried that approach forever like the
malaysia airlines thing is a classic
example like they just you know clung to
this story because it was getting cnn
meager ratings at the time and then they
were in a slow news cycle for a couple
of weeks and so they just pumped that
story so you get don lemon who's already
you know has the brains god gave trout
you know saying things about black holes
eventually right he ran out of stuff to
talk about but they're still clinging to
this model where they just say the same
things over and over and over again and
the uh media environment isn't even what
it was 10 years ago where you have so
many other alternatives you want to hear
a new and fresh perspective you got a
million other things that you can hear
rather than you know one of three or
four broadcast networks and they just
haven't woken up to that reality it's
crazy i think what they realized is that
with the internet and the
infinite you know field of choices
that they need to find their
specific audience that will stick to
them and why it used to be that there
were very few channels to watch you know
we had four major networks or whatever
and then all of a sudden you have the
cable channels and cnn was getting
massive viewership just by virtue of
being 24-hour news i mean they were they
were the original you know 24-hour news
channel so they had the ratings people
would turn it on in airports and hotels
and they work these deals out
with the internet people can choose to
go read whatever news they want yeah and
they can choose the news that's actually
comforting to them and they do which is
bad so cnn realized we better start
pandering as much as possible to a
certain crowd and when trump came out
the stuff that made him the most money
was not liking trump's and they said we
need opinion guys who don't like trump's
another msnbc
how do you recover from that though
because when trump's gone what do you
got left well that's it and the other
part of that story though was the
credibility they lost during that time
because they went so hard after trump
they went down say a trump russia
collusion rabbit hole that you know i
just don't even know how that you can
even call yourself a journalist after
publishing that stuff that's crazy for
so many years i mean and again they just
are like buffaloing through all this
like like new media doesn't exist like
you know the fact that they have been
undermining trust on on the like the
major story that occupied a news cycle
for three years turned out to be false i
mean they're just pretending they want
awards for it and they attack people
that call them out on it the people who
from the very beginning were like
they're full of crap there's no evidence
there's no documents there's nothing to
prove their story i think they were
vilified i think the new york times won
a pulitzer for um
for their trump russia reporting in what
was it like march of 2019 and the
mueller report happened like three
months later i mean like literally
everything they just won a polisher for
was like invalidated it's madness and
yet they just pretend that
these things aren't happening like i
look i mean this is a great show i'm a
fan of the show i'm here tonight because
i enjoy it but i've also got a book
remote i'm here because you guys are
legit competition to the cable news
you've got a million subscribers on on
youtube cable news people don't think
that way they're still kind of you know
in the dark about this and it's because
they're so egotistical they don't
understand americans are hungry for
other perspectives they don't understand
we have alternatives and they don't
understand they're frankly getting
better information elsewhere they're
also
public companies so they have to make
profits this company will make profits
because it's awesome and well designed
but it's not about the profits it's
about the message
i get invited on fox news a lot more
than i that used to i've been i used to
be invited on periodically for like
specific stories now it just feels like
the guys over at fox will hit me up you
know twice a month or whatever and be
like hey do you want to come on this
segment
you know i just did a segment the other
day and i was thinking to myself
afterwards like why am i even doing this
anymore like they hit me up and they're
like yo we'll send it a van it's really
easy it's 10 minutes you just pop in and
i'm like yeah sure why not right and
then i this time around i got out of the
truck they have these satellite vans or
they're not satellite vans they're
they're cell bonding vans and i was just
like why am i even bothering going on
this
you know to to do talk for a few minutes
and i'll tell you like my thought
process was
shows like this
it's raw
it's just a couple hours we talk i do
have a bunch of stories i'm like i want
to get to and i don't want to i don't i
want to make sure we don't just beat a
dead horse and talk about too much over
and over again so i'll be like okay
let's you know try and change the
subject on this you know so there is
some structure to it but for the most
part if conversation happens a
conversation happens you go on fox news
and they're like
some days they're like it's going to be
five minutes and they talk to me for ten
and i'm like what's going on like
they're still talking to me and then
they were like you were doing so well
they just kept going with it and i'm
like i got a deadline i gotta be inside
and there are some times where they're
like it's a ten minute segment and
they're like oof and they just cut it
off after the first sentence because
they don't want you to say what you're
saying or they don't like what you're
saying and i'm just like people don't
want this
people don't want you know
i think there's i think this is why you
see
the key demo ratings for these big
networks are in the gutter their overall
ratings are good if you go by key demo
we absolutely beat all of the big cable
shows
i mean for a number of years now i just
refused to do interviews with the
mainstream media there's nothing to win
a lot of people you don't get that
engagement you don't get that kind of
honest real
uh kind of conversations that could
really delve into issues that people
could get to know you from that people
could interact and engage with you like
here i got the comment section open
because your voice matters i i want to
interact with you people back there they
have makeup rooms they they live in this
kind of world of delusion where they
think they're all mighty and powerful
and they have the money to pretend that
they are but at the end of the day it's
just pretend for them well i'll push
back a little and simply say that you
know for the time being
a lot of these organizations still do
bring a level of sort of resources if
nothing else and or you know some degree
of professionalism in terms of editing
other things that most you know online
media outlets
uh that are competing with our new media
outlets haven't quite gotten caught up
to some of them have more of them will
we will get to that point um you know so
they still do some good work and but and
they're still very influential within
you know a lot of narrow circles that
matter republican congressmen are
watching
fox news and and that matters you know
trump is watching fox news but i would
push back and i would say that uh when
when we're talking about ethics the
mainstream media has a very lower
quality than people online look at wmds
look at the lies that they told them the
effects that they've been having on
people that cost people to die and
republicans care more about the opinion
of the new york times than they do of
the opinion of their constituents yes
yeah and but this is the thing one thing
about trump i will say is i think trump
woke up republicans specifically and
americans more generally to the problems
of getting mixed up with the media um
trump was the first you know sort of
large public figure that basically said
you know what i don't have to do i don't
have to leak the story the new york
times i can leak this story to breitbart
or whatever and it'll have just as much
an effect and that was like a really
threatening realization to them the fact
that he could go through alternative
media and frequently did and that was i
think what made the media hate them a
lot but you know going back to what you
were saying earlier i mean it is totally
true that the way that the main media
has become so adversarial and openly so
politically i tell this to ordinary
people all the time i i this happens
i'll talk to people they will they'll
just because i you know know people out
in the hinterlands like you're you know
a journalist someone from the chicago
tribune or new york times called me and
they wanted to talk about this thing
that's happening in my business and i'm
not like 95 percent of them like
absolutely not do not talk you know the
story of mayo gate
uh no so uh let's tell the story of mayo
gate there was a tweet from the north
carolina gop
it was a quote from a story about a
business that said inflation's really
bad
we are spending 200 bucks a week more in
may's
and so all of a sudden because it came
from republicans democrats huffington
post slate i don't know a bunch of these
i think it was late a bunch of these
lefty lefty outlets picked up the story
and said
that the restaurant owner was lying
about the cost of mayonnaise to make joe
biden look bad
they did this ridiculous math where they
were like if the consumer price index is
up 5
200 would mean that they're spending 3
700 per week on mayonnaise as i say a
month is 200 bucks per week on menus and
so you know what i did um journalism i
called the restaurant
and i said
is this you know such-and-such
restaurant i'm looking for the owner and
i said i'm one of the partners and i
said i saw a story where um there's a
statement from one of your you know
principals that you were spending 200 a
week more on mayonnaise and you went oh
yeah yeah we we go through about you
know i can't remember the exact numbers
but he's like we use these big five
gallon drums we've got 10 of them
they've jumped up about 18 bucks per per
uh per you know canister or whatever so
you know do the math it's like 180 bucks
200 bucks you rise it up and i was like
oh
yeah why do you use so much mayonnaise
oh it's it's we use it for everything
it's it's for you know people put on
their sandwiches of course we use salad
dressings it's used in recipes so we go
through quite a bit of it and i was like
what's your restaurant's capacity it's
250 and i'm like okay so if you're
hitting near capacity or half capacity
everybody gets a side of mayo or
coleslaw or something on their sandwich
yet going through mayonnaise but they
just made up a response accuse this guy
of lying
and that's why you know
like the guy i ended up getting a call
back from someone else there who was
just like i can't believe this is
happening we didn't say anything
political
and i'm like this is why you don't talk
to the press i'm actually getting i've
been getting hit up to do shows from
people and uh shout out to clint russell
and bob murphy econ uh but
i'm concerned even
just youtubers because if someone does
an edited show like i'm already
ridiculous on an unedited live show if
someone wants to take me out of context
they could destroy the way i seem so
even like legit youtube channels that
edit their stuff i'm warning signs go
off when they ask me so as someone who's
a 20-plus year veteran of you know major
news organizations this is something i
will say that has been a huge shift in
the last five or ten years with this
milkshake ducking thing that did not
used to happen
and now all of a sudden if a private
citizen finds themselves in the
crosshairs of a national political story
and it cuts against what the media wants
they will destroy them do you want to
explain the milkshake duck thing so um
i don't even remember the actual origins
of the meme somebody would have to like
look that up for me but but basically
it's like internet speak for you know
taking you know going through a person's
like social media history and trying to
find you know something to um discredit
them um when they become a matter when
when they become the center of public
the original meme was something to do
with like a guy who created a comic or
something that everyone loved trying to
be a nazi or something like that yeah i
can't remember exactly but but there was
that remember the classic example i
think was who's that guy who like asked
a question in a debate that was wearing
a sweater oh yeah yeah ken bone yeah
everyone was so enamored with him or
whatever and then like two days later
you know everyone's like digging up the
fact that he had said some you know off
color thing on reddit once upon a time
this is a the milkshake duck is from
ben ward yeah at pixelated boat on
twitter
i uh um i'm pretty bullish on some kind
of national dissolution peaceful divorce
national divorce civil war whatever
and you're polish on civil war yeah like
i don't mean to say that something i
want you something you want oh you're
saying that you're you're thinking the
likelihood of it yeah i'm i'm looking at
it like wow that's gonna happen
and it's it's crazy that there's been a
lot of things that you know uh jack
murphy likes to mention this it was last
year in january we had a conversation
about a lot of things we predicted a
bunch of stuff that was going to happen
based on what we were seeing and i
remember jack hitting up being like dude
you need to go back and watch the
episode we did it was like the first
guest we ever had oh yeah and he was
like we predicted a lot i was like
really he's like yeah dude and i was
like wow
so i see these things in media
and i i think one of the things about it
there are a lot of people who tell me
i'm crazy for bringing it up
but now it's starting to change man i
thought it was so funny uh i'm not
afraid to speak my mind and give my
opinions even if people think they're
dumb like when i was like i didn't like
dune everyone's like you're insane dunes
the greatest movie i'm like i don't care
if i if i feel the way i'll say it
back in the day when i talk about civil
war people would be like you're nuts
it'll never happen now i have people
being like so you've been talking about
civil war like i did russell brandt's
podcast and he's like yeah yeah you said
civil war and then i go through all the
details we had shooting in pacific
northwest let me show you this story
so you can explain so you can understand
how i feel
this is a tweet from max blumenthal he's
a leftist and it's from a show primo
radical he says noam chomsky doubles
down on his previous call for the state
to segregate the unvaccinated from
society quote how can we get food to
them well that's actually their problem
only play this video when you talk about
folks having the freedom to you know
separate if they don't want to abide by
these vaccine mandates what would that
look like on a practical level does that
mean that folks uh need to to stay home
and have like groceries delivered to
them does it mean like separated
communities of folks who are
unvaccinated or just you know how do you
think this would practically play out
same way as with people who say that i
don't want to worry i don't want to
accept traffic rules
i suppose
he said it's an attack on my liberty to
make me stop at a red light it's
government overreach i don't want the
state to have that power over my private
life well such people
have to be
they should have the decency to remove
themselves from the community
if they refuse to do that
then measures have to be taken to
safeguard the community from them
then comes the practical question that
you ask
how can we get food to them well that's
actually their problem
of course if they really become
destitute then yes you'd have to move in
with some measure to
secure their survival uh just as you do
with people in jail for example
so there you go this is noam chomsky he
is a prominent figure on the left that's
why they interview him and this had to
be probably the most infuriating thing
i've ever heard but at least noam
chomsky has become senile enough to
admit what they want to do
it's not about vaccines it's about
mandate you saw him talk about traffic
laws yeah yeah if someone blew a stop
sign are we going to put him in a camp
and then and then deliver food to them
no
but think about what he's saying the
same thing that happens if someone
refuses to abide by traffic laws yeah
they get a slap on the wrist they get a
20 ticket yeah and they're told to go
home
so when i brought up vaccine madness i
said i tweeted this
i said the left tries claiming that
vaccine mandates have been around
forever weird i don't recall being
carded for my medical information
entering a bar before but if you say so
and then income the leftists being like
all of these mandates for like smallpox
smallpox mandate supreme court ruling
1905. it was the jacobson ruling i
believe it was called it was over a five
dollar fine the guy didn't want to pay
the equivalent of 150 for not getting
the vaccine they didn't say you weren't
allowed to go to restaurants they didn't
say to stay home they didn't say we were
going to segregate you from society they
didn't say we were going to cut you off
from food they said pay about 150 bucks
and you're done and he said no took him
to court the court said you know what
they can fine you over this and that was
it and from that ruling we got i think
it was was the back ruling in the 1927
where they ended up sterilizing 70 000
women because they used the
justification of government-mandated
medical procedures to sterilize people
the state deemed imbeciles so when you
see noam chomsky say segregate these
people from society and if they want
food that's their problem i hope you're
paying attention to what prominent
leftist figures are saying they want to
do to your kids then don't come to me
and say but tim i can't stand up for my
rights my kids need food congratulations
when you don't nom chomsky's going to
come and take it away
and it's not just chomsky it's not just
commentators it's world leaders like the
prime minister of new zealand that was
asked directly
are you creating a two-class society of
people who are vast and unvaxed with
special privileges for the ones that are
vast she responded resoundingly yep and
and that's what they're literally doing
in implementing as far as policies here
and we have to be made aware of that so
plagues have been a major thing in human
history and there actually is this like
extensive legal tradition of the state
having extraordinary powers in the time
of plague to do all kinds of things for
quarantines and all this other stuff but
that was back again when you're talking
about smallpox pre-vaccine that like you
know people were like dying in the
streets with open sores and like was
incredibly contagious that was you know
killing you know three-quarters of
entire towns like the survivability rate
of covet is you know extremely high and
they're treating this like it's you know
again smallpox pre-vaccine i mean
it doesn't it never has justified these
kinds of draconians ian brought up a
really good point uh recently when he
asked us about you know where the line
is in terms of vaccine mandates and and
i was like i don't think what we're
seeing warrants the kind of mandates
they're doing and then ian was like okay
so but but if it's ebola then their
rights be damned and i was like it's a
good point you're like airborne ebola
aerosol eyes and people's insides are
liquefying and they're dying and then i
was just like you know
i think about it and i'm still like then
you should isolate yourself from from
everyone else if you don't want to take
those risks which which brings me back
to the original ruling that the left
tries to cite and i want to say i'll say
two things one
they said if you don't get the vaccine
it is a five dollar fine
just like if you blow a red light they
say it is a fifty dollar ticket five
dollars back then was about 150 bucks
now as i stated
so for noam chomsky to say the same
thing that happens the other thing they
bring up is schools mmr vaccines yeah if
i want to go to mcdonald's for a
cheeseburger i don't have to present my
cards
because of schools
still something completely different but
my my greater point was
if they're openly saying
if we have the power we will do this to
you
then the only outcome i see i see this i
see two groups of people pointing the
finger saying live by my rules or else
technically it's not true the right
tends to be saying leave me the f alone
and the left says shut your goddamn
mouth we are going to lock you up if we
have to there's also a lot of pushback
against chomsky against his point of
view here one person writes glad i was
able to learn a lot from reading and
watching chomsky and glad i was smart
enough to learn when it was time to stop
listening to chomsky
another person just chatted here also
noam chomsky is the is the grinch who
stole liberty yeah and i would have to
agree with that this is
my entire life it's it's insane people
have been following noam chomsky around
transcribing his every utterance like
literally that's what they do with him
and the only other figure in human
history i can think of where they did
this was jesus christ
and he is not jesus christ i mean like
he said so many like dumb and ill
considered things over the years i think
he happens to have said some interesting
things over the years what he was saying
about corporate media in the 80s was
interesting
but you know he's he's spouted off on so
many topics over the years that go so
far beyond his quote-unquote domain of
linguistics or whatever it is
that the fact that we're still listening
to him at this point in time never mind
that he's saying things that are
terrifyingly authoritarian but let's
let's think about
what he's saying
when he says
we would need to
take measures to protect society
from the people who won't get vaccinated
he is operating under the assumption
that he is society that he controls it
and that it's his
it's not true so here's what i posted
when he said the food actually that's
their problem no gnome actually that's
your problem farmers support trump 85 to
12. oh boy truckers support trump 10 to
1.
so if you think you're going to isolate
these people from society and then you
will be trying to be the nice person to
figure out how to feed them you're
sorely mistaken yeah you'll isolate the
people who bring the food to your city
and then they'll give you the finger and
you'll say but wait i'm hungry
that's not sugar-coated he's calling for
camps he's calling for people to be
relocated outside of society outside of
their homes put into special facilities
where they are concentrated
and then we would
ensure their survivability much like
jail australia is already building camps
for 2020 and 2022 and 2023 they're still
building even more on top of that so
this is not even in the realm of
conspiracies this is not only just being
talked about by chomsky this is being
activated in parts of the world right
now where they have camps for people who
don't comply the cdc director just came
out today and said that they she has a
plan for unvaxed government employees
and police and it's to re-educate and to
provide counseling for them she said
specifically quote there's a plan should
these people not want to be vaxxed uh
what's the plan was the exact detail she
didn't really get into all the word
re-educate unironically i mean you you
you you're the bad person you see that
new zealand prime minister lady yeah no
i saw that when she was when she was
asked by a reporter are you going to be
creating two classes of people yes
that's exactly what we're doing
yes
i
i think it's cool they're not even
hiding it they're so
emboldened by the mainstream media
cheering them up and blowing smoke up
there took us his family-friendly show i
would have said
they're shifting the definition of
what's vaxxed now yeah now all of a
sudden it's going to include you know
you don't have your seventh booster for
the you know um you know all my
crosstalk just like they expected the
definition for herd immunity as well
they normally surely destroy the
language university of denver flu
vaccine mandate
you know i i'm just so astounded that we
as a species can make so many movies
books shorts about apocalyptic futures
and nightmare dystopias and right now
we're living in one and people are like
this is fine
seeing that story about noam chomsky and
then seeing people high profile blue
check marks agreeing with them you
really you you realize who the nazis
would have been well
there's also something here which is
just that our culture is so
empty and devoid of meaning here now
yeah look i'm just speaking as a
christian you know like i live for
things other than what my government
does on a day-to-day business uh on a
day-to-day
on on a day-to-day basis um but the fact
that these people are the number one
thing that they're afraid of is just
dying constantly you know what i'm not
afraid of dying i'm professionally not
afraid of dying for something i believe
in and once upon a time that was the
dominant attitude in america people had
things they were willing to die for you
know that's a really interesting thing
you maybe just realized something i'm
not afraid of dying i'm afraid of not
living
so for me when they say things like you
have to live in a cubicle locked down
you can't go outside people would rather
not live
but be alive i'm the other way around i
would rather risk my life in order to
live
right well look they're going to get to
live and and mark zuckerberg's metaverse
or whatever it is whatever vr goggles
they bolt to your head and their
beautiful pod
but people are going to gleefully enter
the matrix
you know it's it's omar
that's the classic huxley orwell
distinction right yeah i mean like you
know everyone's here well but you know
the reality is huxley probably got it
more right than or well you know we're
all gonna sleepwalk into this because it
seems like the fun thing to do i
actually think luke got it more right
revenge of the nerds or the other ones
you are here
yeah
with all of the dystopian novels and
we're in between all of them because it
is government overreach but it is the
pleasurification it also is the
censorship like fahrenheit it also is
v for vendetta right yeah that's the
funniest part very accurately um there's
so many things in those movies that are
playing out in true life it's it's kind
of awesome why are we so good at
predicting all of this
reacting to any of it and why do people
cheer on the people fighting against the
big tyrannical governments and
corporatists but yet on may on you know
in the real world they're cheering them
on like julian assange but then trump
was like i don't know who julian assange
is well this is my favorite point to
make about the original star wars new
hope
i always ask people like are you a fan
of star wars yeah sure you like the a
new hope uh the original one yeah like
the fact that the original trilogy yeah
you think a story about a bunch of
religious zealots who come from a desert
take a cargo plane and blow up a
military base is a cool story
i mean i guess but i was also raised
mormon so uh
um
exactly you know so my former colleague
jonathan lass is a guy that wrote the
famous essay about how the you know the
the empire were actually the good guys
right um that you know got a lot of
traction back in the day yeah i mean i
totally see where you're coming from
with that i'd love to do a series of
short films
villains as the good guys
so we could do a ton of different movies
and do like a five-minute short film
where it just breaks down just like a
quick you know overview of the bad guys
actually the good guy and darth vader i
tried for so long just like luke just
tried just like that karate kid video on
youtube that describes karate kid but in
a totally different light and
perspective right right but they made a
show about it yeah and cobra kai
basically but you know darth vader he's
a disabled veteran bro there you go he's
he's a he's a war hero of the clone wars
if you joke about it it just may come
true there was a galactic civil war and
he lost his limbs fighting against
religious zealots to save
you know what government in chapels now
of course we know the emperor was
secretly fomenting all of this stuff
that's besides the point
you know darth wasn't in on it
well mark asked the question why we're
so good at like coming up with these
stories but we're so bad at reacting to
them and i think that is because people
who create art have a much deeper
understanding of human nature than the
people who make our policies because
looking at the way democrats are trying
to handle this pandemic they are
assuming that people are going to go
along with them if they force them to do
it like have you ever met an american
that is not a good way to get an
american to do anything look at these
look at these protests in new york
you've seen these these
crossing the bridge chanting let's go
brandon exactly and the day before that
the kyrie irving protest outside of the
barclays center where they stormed and
tried to get into the barclays center
and there was they pretty much had a lot
of people out there
all chanting let kyrie play
like i'm glad the fight in this country
isn't you know dead but having said that
you know i don't know maybe this is
you know my age and you know stature
talking as it were but
i i have a feeling that even 25 years
ago so much what we're seeing would have
been a non-starter yeah and not just
because of the technological stuff
that enables this but simply because the
cultural attitudes were like so much
stronger in terms of and people were
stronger healthier happier and had more
families and now we have a lot less of
that but then all of the mainstream
stuff would have been put on abc and it
would have been fact we would have
thought oh millions of people have been
this and that and like yeah no he's
right vietnam war i mean there was a
huge push but that was they realized
they realized the mistake they made by
putting cameras there so they didn't do
it for the first iraq war they decided
not to show the doors getting kicked in
in the first iraq war in the 90s yeah
they showed like a news reporter sitting
on a tank driving through the desert but
they didn't show like kids getting mowed
down in their houses and stuff as the
soldiers were kicking the doors in and
white phosphorus there was an age of
muck-breaking journalism that did make a
big impact but it's hard to kind of
weigh these things it's hard to really
assess them
by not living through them and and and
only having the reports from what
happened uh of the reports not the
actual events so it's hard to say
exactly what was the lynch point if it
was the media if not and i think it's
impossible to answer those questions can
i ask you mark how old you are i'm 45.
45 all right so you're not old enough
i'm i'm thinking well i guess you are a
gen xer right yeah ian you're barely a
gen x or 42 yeah last year i was
watching the music video for gotta get
away by the offspring oh you're familiar
with the uh my high school band opened
for them for the elsewhere
no way for real for real wow cool what
was your band called uh a really crappy
high school band no one's ever heard of
what what what year did you shout out
this was this was literally like
a month before smash came out this would
have been like 1993 at the madrona hill
winery which is a venue in portland that
no longer exists which by the way it's a
really bad idea to have underage bands
playing at a winery yeah it is
out there so the offspring story i was
reading about it so when i was younger
they were like my favorite band when i
was like a little kid learning play
guitar
and now they're just
amazing corporate shills they fired
their drummer because he couldn't get
vaccinated because he has guillain barre
syndrome and so i was just like
reading about you know that their album
ignition
sold i think 15 000 copies when it first
came out i think it was epitaph and then
when smash came out it just took the
country by storm i think it might still
be like the biggest selling record to
ever come out in an independent record
yes that's fact that's true
and so these guys were like true punk
rock
underdogs they weren't really going to
go anywhere then all of a sudden it was
mainstream
i'm watching this music video forgot to
get away which was i think it was their
third single off of smash which is like
as you mentioned the biggest independent
release of all time
and i see these like young people
moshing and you know just raging out and
like this teenage angst from gen x and
now gen x have become such like
pro-establishment shills rage on behalf
of the machine they're just totally in
favor of the machine bad religion
totally in favor of the machine so
morello is doing a newsletter for the
new york times right now
he has done one of those masterclass
things i mean
it's i
he is what the poster boy for selling
out so you're a little bit young i guess
though but like what happened man i mean
you were old enough to see smash come
out you played
what happened to this generation how did
they go from being
like
what you got to understand about a punk
album
that this music was not popular it was
not mainstream
and then all of a sudden a million
albums are sold or whatever it's like is
smashing records and all of a sudden now
it is becoming mainstream i guess these
people the the offspring have a song on
their first album whose name i can't say
because it's a crime to say i'm not
kidding yeah they removed it eventually
it's no longer the only way you can
listen to it on youtube by finding the
full album version and then it's the
last song on the album we cannot say the
name of this song it is a crime to say
because it involves the president spicy
they get rid of it eventually
so it's it's almost like these these
these guys are anti-establishment up
until someone slides the money under
their door and then all of a sudden
they're willing to fellate the state so
i'm kind of a music journalist and i
could go off forever on the whole you
know alternative indie thing and like
what happened specifically there but
just to go back to sort of the the
broader cultural thing um
there's this humorous name joe queen and
he wrote this book that's basically
jeremiah against the baby boomers of
which he is one and there's this great
line in there about the baby boomers he
says
they were not the first generation to
sell out but they were the first
generation to sell out and then insist
they hadn't
and
i think that's largely true of like
every successive generation since then i
think the ones that have been subject to
this onslaught of popular culture and
mass media it's very hard to get old and
not you know withstand the peer pressure
and be kind of like a true sort of like
american you know um rugged
individualist
um in that environment it's amazing it's
amazing to me uh listening to a couple
of the songs the offspring put out
americana they had why don't you get a
job
literally a song about getting a job
because you're a lazy bum who won't pay
the bills then they had the song um i
can't remember which album this was i
don't think it might have been a
conspiracy one i'm not sure uh hit that
which is about hookup culture and how
our country's basically in trouble
because people are just going around
partying and hooking up and not caring
about having kids and a family and i'm
like talk about a conservative punk rock
band but now where they're at it's like
you put the money in their hands rage
against the machine quickly rages on
behalf of that machine in two seconds
well the rage against was saying though
for let's be clear that always pissed me
off right um you know they their first
record came out on like sony and
colombia and they're all talking about
the marks in their their their minor
notes and all of that they were never
raging against the machine this is this
is a true story at the 2016 um
presidential sorry the republican
national convention in cleveland
prophets of rage were doing one of their
um
their lo which was tom morrell's like
side project with chuck d they were
doing some appearance at some protest or
whatever and i literally like leaped
over the bushes and like track down tom
morello and i asked him finally after
like 20 years i said
does the irony of getting you know large
crowds to shout f you i won't do what
you tell me you know in unison over and
over again did that ever like occur to
you does it ever bother you
and literally he said something like to
me like he had never even thought of it
um and like that's the issue in a
nutshell like these people think they're
rebelling when they're not they're
literally doing the opposite they're
literally encouraging people to march in
lockstep and somehow telling themselves
that they're anti-establishment at the
same time that cognitive dissonance is
killing us yeah that's a very good point
and i think we were at that protest uh
2016 at the cleveland was the dnc or rnc
uh rnc at least i remember talking to
chuck d there uh specifically about
relating issues but
you made a very good point you know
there's nothing
better that could be ever promoted is
for individualism people to think for
themselves and to just be critical
thinkers and a lot of these people are
like cheer for me clap for me and you
just gotta love multi-million dollar
communist you definitely don't have to
be smart to be a musician they that was
one thing in high school was like if
you're not smart be a musician pretty
much i was at vidcon a few years ago
yeah the big youtube convention
and i saw some little kids
and as i'm walking past one kid goes
there's got to be like 10 years old he
goes you have 80 followers how did you
get so many followers and then some
other kids like dude i have 93 on
instagram and i'm like these kids are
going to be narcissists
right entrepreneurs the internet
i want to hear what you think guys think
about the internet and how it changed
the music industry completely like we
had nirvana you know didn't just scream
it out and like all fake then the
internet came out and
it is kind of awful i mean the
underground music scene isn't fake
that's it when you get together with
your friends of course of course i'm
saying like when i was reading about the
offspring i was genuinely surprised by
their history from they made an album
that i mean the song uh tehran
is a is a great song i love that song
are you familiar with with that at all
yeah the original it's just a good song
whether whether or not you like the
message
then they had uh ignition come out and
they weren't selling they were nobodies
the music wasn't popular imagine you
know just like writing music you know
people is not it's not mainstream and
then all of a sudden it becomes
mainstream
that right there is where i'm like wow
that's the coolest thing ever and then
to see how they instantly became just
corporate machine i'm just like wow that
like that's the whole idea yeah you know
all of a sudden they're like hey we made
it we got to preserve this power we've
made and not be true to ourselves yeah
well what happened in the early 90s
there was a real anomaly culturally um
and i think that's what made it so
impactful though um in the sense that
there was this very much a diy
corporate suspicion culture in you know
gen x um you know punk rock was all
about rebelling against that in in an
actually sincere way you know and there
were people like ian mckay and other
things like that that were actually
committed to that um you know and i
remember when sonic youth signed a
geffen there was like a lot of
hand-wringing among people like you know
is this a thing that they are allowed to
do because they're such beacons of
integrity and of course sonic youth were
like yeah we need health insurance you
know we're like old and have a family
now and like you could be like somewhat
sympathetic to that but it was also true
that
um
the music industry was a victim of
itself in terms of they had you know and
i think they're sort of parallel so like
what's going on today in a lot of ways
where they had like force-fed so much of
the same crap to people like when i was
growing up in the late 80s and you
turned on the radio you had two choices
led zeppelin or whitney houston yeah and
that was like it um and for people were
desperate for some other thing and then
when like nirvana and some of these
other things started to like really
break through the music industry didn't
know what to do themselves they were
just throwing money at bands hoping that
something would stick and as a result
what happened was is you got all of
these you know bands that you know never
in a million years like who on earth
would sign dinosaur junior to a major
major label record deal um
but you know the fact that a band like
dinosaur junior actually got you know
250 thousand dollars to record now meant
that they were able to do something
great they never would have been able to
do so it was actually that marriage of
sort of corporate you know um money
combined with
what that allowed them to do in terms of
well at least back in the day before you
had plug-ins and laptops and recording
technology sorry i'm going off into
tangent here um you know you'd actually
matter whether you got into an expensive
studio with trained recording engineers
and things like that um so it was
actually a confluence of of
establishment and you know the
underground that actually made things
good weirdly enough and that was i think
for a long time kind of a strength where
there were there were aspects of
american culture where you know sort of
the trained well-resourced establishment
would meet up with originality and that
was american innovation and we used to
do you know obviously there were always
corporate sellouts but we used to see
those kinds of leaps regularly where all
of a sudden the establishment would
catch wind was something that was going
on that was new and original exciting
and those things would marry up and
we're not seeing that anymore in fact
you know what we're seeing right now
with the media establishment you know
they should be like figuring out what
the next thing is but they're still
clinging to the cable news business
model the issue i suppose is when the
left started to uh
there's a lot of things that happened in
the culture war that resulted in the
left becoming morally authoritarian
but because we've always kind of been a
culture of hey racism is bad sexism is
bad we should respect each other respect
civil liberties
when the more authoritarians adopted
those stances advertisers just went look
nobody wants to be a racist so we'll
just put money behind whatever they say
and will not put money by anything they
complain about it's like the dave
chappelle thing yeah why should anyone
cancel dave chappelle from a from a
festival because they're scared of the
activists showing up and making them
look bad and them losing money
so what should have happened if you if
you look at at least when i was growing
up the moral authoritarian right the
religious and many of the democrats were
not cool and so nobody cared right it
was fun to be anti-establishment to rage
against the machine and that's what was
making money so they said
now the the big companies are like
we're going to get a bunch of protesters
and we're going to lose money because
they're unwilling to compromise
there you go then you lose it yeah so i
think the interesting thing is we're
going to start seeing
we are saying this babylon be
absurdly funny and predicting the future
apparently apparently south psychic
prophecy
they do a really good job of poking so
much fun that these things actually they
just end up happening
and it's and it's they've been doing a
lot better than the onion has because
when you're scared to be offensive you
don't you're not funny
so what i think we'll start seeing is
now people who don't care about being
offensive which tend to be the cultural
right with whatever right wing actually
means at this point
they're gonna make shows they're going
to make movies they're going to do
comedy specials everyone's going to love
it i think the left is
shutting down their own industry by
being scared to take risks and actually
challenge i think the battle on beam
thing makes me very nervous when when
you they'll do stories and for instance
like just ridiculous ridiculous like joe
biden makes declares it illegal to be a
man and then it'll be like ahaha so and
then no two months later
joe biden declares it illegal and it's
like they see that and they're like oh
okay people didn't say no to it that's a
green light let's go so it's like an
authoritarian gateway if you're not
careful satire can be uh i don't know
i i i i disagree i think it's it's just
making fun of the absolute
ridiculousness of our current society
one of the things that i just retweeted
from the babylon bee is their latest
headline saying quote fauci hopes his
experiments on puppies will distract
everyone from experiments he performed
on humanity for the past 18 months so
it's like it's social commentary to the
highest level of using
comedy as a way to make people laugh at
the absurdity of reality and you know
there are some people bowing down there
are some people giving up but but there
still is a need a hunger for those real
honest real discussions uh and very
interestingly netflix uh just launched a
new show called inside job and it was
number one trending and i i just watched
one episode of it and like my jaw
dropped to the floor i was like no
freaking way i mean they brought up
issues that we would say here
automatically cut uh and and they they
brought up all the conspiracies that
ever existed in a brilliant funny way
from bilderberg
and then even deeper level stuff that
you wouldn't even imagine so there they
just released a very spicy
cartoon show that that goes into how
corporations are controlling the world
um i still haven't made up my mind on it
it's funny but but it also is very deep
i still haven't watched all the episodes
i'm in the process of watching it but
for them to release that on the backdrop
of chappelle might be sending a message
i might be reading it into too much of
it there's a lot of things i'm critical
of netflix about but um i think there's
a reason this show and other shows are
doing so well and have such a you know
loving caring audience that are even
here when that they're not even prompted
to be here unlike cnn cnn has everything
going for them we don't and and i'll
tell you why
so uh a moment ago
we talked about civil war some people
might say that's crazy fine if you think
it's crazy by all means you can think
whatever you want i must be crazy i
don't care on major networks will they
talk about this probably not some of
them maybe we recently saw msnbc
actually run a segment said could we be
facing a second american civil war now
this is a conversation that's been in
mainstream newspapers
for years
but see on this show we're willing to
talk about this from fox news arrest
fouchy trends on twitter as doctor faces
criticism for controversial virus
research testing on dogs i think there's
only one cable tv show that would
actually get more serious than us and
you know who that is would you have a
guess one cable cable tv fred got felt
he's pretty good but no that's kind of
joker carlson tucker carlson
tucker carlson goes a lot further than
i would you know on a lot of these
issues so when we talk about fouchy and
and people wanting to be arrested and
stuff oh we'll talk about these ideas
we'll talk about the potential conflict
of civil war
tucker goes
all in on all of it so that's why i
think obviously his ratings are so high
and then why is it that all these other
networks running from the garbage
because it's fake and everyone knows
it's fake and they're not talking about
real things you go outside there's no
food on the shelves at your store you're
asking yourself what's going on you turn
on cnn nothing orange man bed you turn
on msnbc nothing orange man bed you turn
on fox and they're like inflation's
better that's fault or worse and you
open up the washington post and it's
lower your expectations right why would
i expect there to be pasta and frozen
vegetables in my local grocery store
both of which they've been like running
low on forever now yeah um yeah it's
it's it's really something but let's
we'll let's talk about this arrest fauci
thing because
i don't know if fauci should be arrested
over this there's a story going around
where it shows two dogs they're beagles
and their heads are secured in a box
full of infected sand flies and the dogs
had their vocal cords slit so they
couldn't bark or whimper as their faces
were devoured by ravenous insects
now a lot of people are saying should be
arrested for it
and
i think there's a couple of things that
are that are good here people are
starting to wake up to the kind of
research being done for their for their
benefit for their privileges a lot of
this research is unnecessary and insane
and people are asking like why would you
do that we know the flies would devour
the face of the dog and put it in agony
but i think a lot of people need to
realize
the benefits the wonderful technology
the medicines you have it's because we
experiment in animals sometimes dogs
yeah and actually specifically with sand
flies i don't know exactly what they
were researching with sand flies but
with sand flies they're major carriers
of parasitic diseases which are one of
the few things that we really have
terrible treatments for like this is
disease called leash maniacism that's
very prominent in central and south
america that does like horrible things
to people um like it literally like rots
your face from the inside out
and because it primarily affects poor
people in these areas it's only
government testing that there's really
an incentive to find any sort of cure
because the pharmaceutical companies
aren't in it because there's no you know
financial incentive for it so yeah i
mean actually i don't know exactly what
they were doing with the sand flies but
i can see where doing you know research
on parasitic diseases for all the havoc
it reeks you know testing on dogs might
be necessary a good friend of mine from
high school is a um is a um
is a
biology professor at ut austin and you
know he talked all about biology what is
he
neurology professor and uh you know he
would tell me all the stories he had to
do and the stories about experiments he
had to do in monkeys and stuff i mean
it's just absolutely necessary for the
advancement of humanity um if you care
about that sort of thing now
as for lying to congress
that's something that maybe we should
talk about right this reminds me about
andrew cuomo how they went after him for
the girl with him diddling with the
girls as opposed to sending all those
old people into nursing homes and it's
like it evokes the emotional
hashtag trending thing where like what
he really should be busted for is lying
to congress well if it's what you said
it was there at least should be a debate
but we shouldn't be giving him the
benefit of the doubt because he doesn't
deserve any of it because he's been
lying through his teeth about so many
things and at least we deserve answers
to really find out what was the true
cause and the true reason of these
studies i mean there's there's even
reports of fouchy funded experiments
that literally were used to destroy
portions of monkey's brain that would uh
magnify terror so they could
scare the crap out of them and study
fear so there's there's so many
different why they would do that yeah
what are they trying to learn about
primate fear exactly and again uh apes
are are
97 percent identical to human dna
there's a lot of weird stuff happening
and there should be a lot more
transparency a lot more accountability
because we have to understand there's
some you know beauty products that are
tested in absolutely cruel and inhumane
ways torture animals and
we can't even describe what happens here
the show would get taken down
immediately all four beauty products
like that there should be a line there
should be a discussion there should be
more information we don't have any of
that we have dr fauci financing
essentially the torturing of puppies why
he did it at this point of view we don't
know but i'm willing to suspect
something far more sinister something
far more worse based on his prior
behavior from my own personal
perspective i think fauci had a mustache
he shaved it off since then but back
then he was twirling it
saying we're gonna kill these dogs yep
the fun i could see it that was it that
was the only reason at this point maybe
let's be honest let's be real like we
don't know that's not a fact we don't
have a smoking gun here but i'm not
willing to exclude that out of our
current reality with the way that he's
been treating humanity but it is insane
that we you know we've got he's gotten
far more attention for the testing on
dogs than they lie in congress about
funding research at the wuhan facility
that likely caused the pancreas to the
point where the death
and and he was denying that he ever did
it uh that he ever said that they were
doing that they ever did gain a function
and then they were like let's play a
clip from rand paul where he comes at
you and they give this three or four
second clip of rand paul and then george
stephanopoulos just lofting softballs
over to him saying and by the way our
experts confirmed you didn't do gain of
uh gain of function
right in fact she's like yeah of course
we didn't do gain of function insane
yeah insane gain of function research
would be the manipulation of viruses to
make them more infectious to human type
cells correct that is correct and you
didn't do that no we only took cells and
and viruses and modified them so that
they would be more infectious to humans
we didn't do gain of functionality and
look how stupid rand paul is let's all
let's all focus on that well what they
re what recently like rewriting the
cdc's website or whatever to redefine
gain of function or whatever i mean it's
insane and the thing is he didn't just
lie about this he got indignant yeah
good job brandon shaking and and and
it's just
dude
and not just that this is connected to
this larger narrative remember facebook
banned all discussion of the lab leak
because it was quote unquote
misinformation for
that was all covering up this our
culture has a rot at the core and there
are corrupt people like fauci
who let me just explain to you the level
of insanity we're dealing with when rand
paul holds up the study
that says chimeric virus creation to
increase infectivity on humans
definition of gain of function
fauci this this study says funded by the
nih and fauci goes we did not fund it
it's like
literally holding the evidence
and then what do you get from the
establishment and from the left and from
msnbc it's not true ignore it
and that's the insanity let's also
mention here again that senator rand
paul is a medical doctor doctor senator
rand paul yes so it's not like he
doesn't have some clue what he's talking
about here when he looks at a research
paper he's an actual trained medical
doctor and then the left goes
he's an ophthalmologist who hasn't
practiced in years doctor fauci's an
infectious disease expert
who hasn't practiced in three decades
rand paul literally volunteers his time
and goes down to places like haiti and
gives free
surgeries to people who can't afford it
so he's been practicing medicine on and
off yes but at the same time the
mainstream media vilified him attacked
him every step of the way because he
correctly now called out dr fauci which
the nih doctor
fauci's own
organization that he was running called
them out on yes and the untrained media
do such a great job of presenting
medical information to us too you know
they're certainly in the cat bird seat
when it comes to criticizing rand paul
yeah everything causes cancer and
everything doesn't i love how the media
does this when i was little i see a
story it was like smelling coffee could
prevent cancer or 11. and it's just like
it was a slow news day they looked up a
journal they said here's a study that
says one thing the next day smelling
coffee could cause cancer news at 11
cholesterol is notorious they'd be like
oh cholesterol's great cholesterol is
bad cholesterol is actually very good
for you watch out for cholesterol i
remember i remember when the news of the
nih letter came out and broke fouche was
on the mainstream media they didn't
question him about this right they were
talking about how great it is that kids
were going to be vaccinated uh from ages
5 to 11 and and and up and and meanwhile
you know there needs to be a debate
there was a yale epidemiologist who was
very important with early coveted
treatment who just came out recently and
said that he would pull his child out of
public school if they have public
vaccine mandates in that particular
school absolutely epidemiologist
epidemiologist yeah yeah epidemiologist
doctor henry risch came out and uh he
put out a very important statement
saying if it comes to it i will
homeschool my child rather than put him
in a public school where he has to take
a vaccine
and he was critically important for
early covet 19 treatment he was the
authority on it and and he deserves to
be heard his voice deserves to be
elevated and i wish there was a debate i
wish there was a conversation between
him and dr fauci who's telling people
that it's going to be great that all
children are going to be vaccinated dr
fauci works in an office with a picture
of himself
a giant portrait of himself wow
that's that's great huh we got pictures
of biden because we love biden lydia's
got a big old picture of you can you
show the people show the people oh you
can't really see it it's a little here
let me zoom out a little bit because
there's a picture of biden because we
love and
look
respect
our
beautiful view it's actually closed up
just listening it's a horror photo yeah
his face is like kind of drooping and
melting off he's got a sinister look as
he smells lydia i love it because he's a
disgusting creep yep man you see the uh
that cornholio pose man
the imaginary jet pack
well we're living in a simulation
do you know red steez is on twitter
stephen miller yeah stephen miller yeah
the other one yeah he put up this thing
was like apparently like one of the
classic symptoms of like dementia
alzheimer's
is clenched fists like that i've seen it
yeah and
look i'm not speculating whether or not
biden has dementia per se but the point
is is if if this were trump or any
republican or anyone that the media
didn't like if this were bernie sanders
this would be you know a week's worth of
news cycles about whether or not he has
dementia i feel that screaming the truth
that someone that doesn't want to hear
it is is fruitless it may have some
impact but it's such a diminishing
return it's like wind resistance
terminal velocity you can't
you can't get past their brain cloud
so there's i'm trying to think of other
ways you got to make them figure it out
on their own like set them up to figure
it out walk into it and be like hey i
figured out that
biden is losing his you know whatever
his mental capacity if that's what's
happening but to tell them that just
doesn't seem they don't seem that it
doesn't seem to yeah uh clenched hands a
symptom of alzheimer's yeah it is it is
but but to ian's point i think that he's
on to something help me zoom in a little
bit more again well this could also
explain sorry just one one small uh
important tidbit here before i take it
off to lydia this could explain why we
are on day 279 of the hundred days of
masking
sorry go ahead yeah yeah for sure well
what i was going to say was that to
ian's point he was talking about how you
can't convince someone to change their
mind by giving them new information
because you're just contradicting them
this is something scott adams talks
about a lot and in general i would
recommend being incredibly compassionate
even when it's really hard
because what is that quote that people
won't care what you told them to only
care how you made them feel at the end
of the day yeah
no i think this is true this is
something that you know conservatives in
general really stink at yeah they need
to like approach the conversation like i
understand
why you you know that you feel this way
i understand that maybe you've had
difficulties because of x y and z but
here you know here's why i'm telling you
that i disagree you know there needs to
be some sort of acknowledgement on a
human level also rather than like you
know i look i like ben shapiro but like
facts don't care about your feelings
doesn't get you very far away feelings
don't care about your facts
i feel what you feel is the way to go
understanding what they feel
that's kind of it's kind of too cold but
when you feel what they're feeling it
sucks because like they're feeling
terrified and like they're losing their
mind but if you allow yourself to feel
it for a minute while you're talking to
them
it's sales and uh manipulation 101 is
the first thing you have to do in order
to change anyone's opinion is have
rapport
and so that's why a very common sales
tactic would be like hey
nice to meet you man where are you from
mark
bend oregon bend oregon no joe no
seriously my brother lives up there i'm
pregnant yeah my brother's amazing i
wonder if you guys ever bumped into each
other that's so cool i can't believe we
have so much in common well i live in
alexandria now but i'm originally from
ben wow
uh so i actually uh
i do have a brother who lives in bend
but so what you do is
when you're when you're doing sales or
fundraising activism you start off just
with like hey nice to meet you like
where are you from
you know you find something and no
matter what they say you say something
to compliment it and show that you share
a positive emotion
and then you're opening the door another
thing we talked about is something
called the yes train get someone to say
yes seven times they're more likely to
acquiesce to whatever your demand is
so like if you want to sell with pizza
you'd be like hey look you you know
you're pr it's lunch time right right
you're looking for food i'd imagine at
some point right and then eventually
okay great i got a pizza right here here
you go you want it right right the last
three times i've been in a car
dealership i've always been complimented
on my shirt huh
i think i was talking about i don't
think my shirt was particularly great i
was talking about my dad and he was like
can you can you believe it they're
they're trying to stop people from being
able to take the vaccine if they want in
these certain places and i was like
that's crazy man if if it was a
dangerous disease then i could
understand like it was like i i just
felt and got what he was saying even
though it wasn't what i agreed with and
and then
immediately started telling him what i
thought
that's the way to get through to people
i i was a little vague about what
transpired just now on purpose the
the unfortunate reality for me was when
i was working at these non-profits is
that there's a very easy formulaic way
to get people to change their opinions
it works every time and if you're
willing to do that you'll win and if
you're not willing to do that then
you're in trouble so being blunt with
people i feel like is the right thing to
do but the right thing isn't always the
effective thing
and so like you mentioned it's actually
one step beyond that
uh it's it's it's actively lying to
manipulate that gets you the most
successful outcome
and uh
man i i think these these these you know
these charity organizations these
non-profits i used to do this stuff once
i found out that they were lying i quit
i couldn't do it i was like i thought i
was being honest i thought i was doing a
good thing and then once you realize
they've actually formulated these lies
specifically to make money off people
and trick them and what my friends
described it me and my friends describe
it as selling hopes and dreams to people
or selling them nothing
like people would go out in the street
and sell hair products and packages they
have these guys that go around and
they'll be like they'll walk up to girls
and be like oh your hair is amazing like
you should definitely check out the
salon and then give them the coupon and
then they get money when the coupon is
used and then we would always laugh like
we you know they'd see us we'd be do
we'd be fundraising and we'd be like we
don't sell anything we literally just
tell people to give us their money and
they do
and they'd be like wow people are
animals we think a lot of times they
were so smart i do for sure but like
like a dog if you treat it right and you
reward it when you want want it to
repeat itself it'll repeat i disagree i
had uh i i knew someone
i met someone at uh columbia who said
that they used um
pavlovian reinforcement to get their
roommate to do chores for them by
offering them candies that they really
liked whenever they would do something
and then when they wanted the dishes
done they would plot the candies and
then be like oh would you mind doing the
dishes they'd be like yeah and then
afterwards she'd hand them some candy
and they were just like they didn't
realize they had been manipulated
let's go to super chats
if you haven't already smash the like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends go to
timcast.com become a member
to support our work in building culture
setting up uh our new you know our new
space at freedom stand we're gonna be
building it out we're gonna try and
figure out what that looks like probably
gonna have a sandwich shop a smoothie
shop a skate shop a game shop a gun shop
i've been doing massive research on the
dome
very exciting
there may be an array of free domes one
another particular place but the place i
stay in new hampshire is a bunch of
domes yeah how it forms together they're
pretty cool yeah but most importantly a
bunch of journalists working at
timcast.com we have new shows we're
building and if you want to support this
show being a member helps but we're
going to have a members only show coming
up we drop them about 11 p.m every night
so definitely you don't want to miss
that but let's read some of your super
chats and again smash that like button
all right make 1984 fiction again says
alec baldwin's career was mostly
peaceful
to all saying prop gun would you be cool
with him killing somebody with a prop
car stabbed with a prop knife hung with
a prop rope there's no prop gun this is
the craziest thing
i understand why they're framing it like
that because if it said alex alec
baldwin shot and killed someone and set
people would assume it was his gun in
the media it was his gun they wanted
what was the sets it was the movies he's
the producer of them he's yeah he's one
of the owners of the props but they
wanted to make sure people knew that he
didn't bring his own weapon and do it so
you actually made a great point earlier
about you know the cultural differences
of this stuff um you know my dad's a
retired marine colonel my dad was an
alternate from wrinkle rifle pistol team
he was like an amazing shot i grew up
shooting and i remember when i was
younger i was learning to shoot like i
pointed the gun in the wrong direction
once i don't remember what happened next
all i know is that my i was on the
ground and i looked up my dad was
holding the gun yep and i was like you
will not do that again
you know um and like that's how
seriously you know people that you know
use guns you know treat the safety of
them i got one i got one for you michael
malus the new right michael likes to say
the new right he asks people do you
think some people are better than others
yes and no i mean i think that everyone
is a sinner i mean the human nature is
inherently flawed and one of the big
problems of our current societies people
don't don't understand that human beings
are inherently sinful and
self-interested well michael says the
new right will just say yes but the left
will justify your hemon haw
and i got a better one
the new right is was it alec baldwin's
fault or not
i mean it's it's crazy to me
yeah like let's let's break this down
alec baldwin is the producer on a movie
there is a gun negligently discharged
multiple times so crew actually walk off
the set protesting
he's then handed the same gun
doesn't check it in defiance of his own
training and then shoots and kills
somebody and they're like it's not his
fault
you got to be insane so nick cersei and
adam baldwin are two some of the two of
the more
uh open right wingers in hollywood but
both guys would sort of distinguish
careers in hollywood and had a lot of
guns on sets and they both came out and
said you were given very specific
instructions about pointing the gun it
is your obligation when they hand you
the gun to double check that it's not
loaded like all of these things
whatever you want to say about
negligence that happened before the gun
got in his hands there's no doubt that
baldwin himself was not negligent for
not checking to see that apparently
there was a live round in the game
somebody tweeted at me so you're saying
that anytime someone wants to drive a
movie on set they got to check the oil
check the gas check the brakes and i was
like
no i'm saying that anytime someone's
doing a scene where they're going to
slam the gas full speed towards the crew
they should check the brakes and the
safety harness the emergency handbrake
and make sure they've gone through the
stunt coordinator because you're risking
people's lives it's not a stunt to drive
a car if they're like we're gonna drive
a car on the block it's not a stunt
if they're like we want you to slam the
gas full speed towards the camera okay
what's our emergency stop do we have do
we have a rope a cable do we have a hand
brake then you will test them out before
doing the stunt so yes
if you're going to hand a gun to
somebody
it should be for a revolver cylinder
should be open they should be
i think it should be unloaded i don't
know exactly what their protocol is it
should be unloaded and if they're going
to be using blanks they should they show
the blank have the actor inspect it
place the blank and say we have placed a
blank inside this gun
if you point this at someone in close
enough range you can kill them they
should be given the full spiel every
time never make assumptions that people
know how to handle these things at least
two people should check the gun at least
i mean even when i'm handling firearms i
always ask someone else to check the
chamber we always do a chamber check
someone else check it and then i check
it and then i'll make sure to put it
away and then it's safe when we're
leaving the range
i'll take my weapon and i'll clear it
block the hammer back and then i'll hand
it to the next person to inspect and
then they do the same thing i was just
watching a gun show on youtube with a
bunch of ex-special forces guys are the
same thing where they were talking about
a particular gun and they passed the gun
around before they even discussed it so
that each one could verify there was no
round right chamber before you were
playing with it before they even brought
it up picked it up all right let's read
some super chats djm says to tim pool
and the rest of the tim cast irl crew
congratulations on 400 episodes oh yeah
your show at teamcast.com continues to
have success we're at 400. we are this
is 400. is this 400. yeah i'm honored we
should celebrate it
400 is that like a number yeah a number
it's a hundred right yeah what what is
this what's the what's quad quadra
centennial yeah that's what that's what
that is yeah
well uh uh we will eat uh wings
all right
sounds great open up packages maybe oh
yeah oh yeah
alessio de monte says yahoo news just
released that the assistant director
that gave baldwin the gun was previously
fired due to another gun incident looks
like they are already starting a story
to help baldwin
or the guy dead and that's what happened
i don't believe any piece of news that i
hear at face value what if like the true
story was that baldwin is part of this
grand democrat conspiracy and they were
like we need to take out this wife of
this lawyer and then he was like i'll do
it i'll do whatever you say they have
heart attack
that's all i have to say can we talk
about like how it turned out alec
baldwin's wife had been faking being
from spain
yeah
i mean that was the craziest thing i'd
heard in forever you know you know
people need to understand about like
assassination is that it would never be
that crazy like they would just they
would just pay some random guy to go
into your neighborhood and then
you know
mug you yeah right car crash car
accidents like or like michael hastings
if you're no but even that it's like
dude that could have been oh no he got
robbed i mean
i'm not going to go there in terms of
speculation but i totally understand why
he was at the seth rich guy you know
like
why people didn't automatically think
that that was just a random dc crime you
know when you're you've got access to
all that sensitive dnc information you
know oh yeah of course of course that's
an investigation there have been plenty
of incidents like that i'm sure that
were foul play but i think the problem
is
you know sometimes
occam's razor is right there's a lot of
people who believe the south rich
conspiracies and stuff but like
i think it's a lot of wishful thinking
oh i think so too i'm just pointing out
that like i totally understand why
people go exactly yeah but yeah i in
that case you never give government the
benefit of the doubt yeah that's true
yeah
but who's to say the government was
involved in it
we should at least have the ability to
answer and question sure sure no i will
say that that there are there's
definitely a lot of like random things
in dc where like so and so who's a
person of some import was standing in
their driveway and
this person came up and something
happened
it was a dirty game very dirty yeah all
right raymond stanley says tim the
members event was rad shout out to every
person and dog there i've had some good
peeps looking forward to free damascus i
should have brought my dog yeah
my dog was there yeah
swiss says remember tim the slow blade
penetrates the shield yup i remember
that from the movie that was before i
walked out torturing tim
all right let's see what we got
bo jess says ian if psilocybin was
actually a threat to the system they
wouldn't allow it to be legalized
that's what they want you to believe
yeah but you got to define threat and
system and all that i it can definitely
alter the way we govern ourselves or
help us change the way we perceive our
own system of governance but i don't
think it would yeah i agree with you i
don't think it's like a destructive
force
jeremy hall says tim if you were to get
into a coma on the zero motorcycle what
plans do you have in place shim cast
luke cast oh personally i vote for ian
cast
as if the plan is
my bed will be placed here in front of
the camera and i'll be intubated and on
life support and that will be the show
and then i'll he'll whisper in my ear
and then i'll tell you what he said well
we'll live stream it and then if you get
like 50 likes treats go down fall on
them it'll be like it'll it'll show the
bed with me unconscious and then it'll
cut to luke and he'll be like that's a
good point tim yeah
and then you know like tim's wrong about
this one and then it'll show me again
and just go
tim actually has a pacemaker wired to
some explosives in the basement so yeah
when his heart stops beating the whole
compact goes sky high it's true just
implodes
a warning like you get 30 seconds yeah
yeah yeah
don jet says dumb law in west virginia
it is illegal to beat your wife so long
as it's done in public on sunday on the
courthouse steps i don't believe that i
kind of looked that up that's amazing
that can't be true
could be
all right let's see we got
tristan lee dobler says dave chappelle
stole multiple jokes that owen benjamin
made years ago and got blacklisted for
watch the greatest comedian oh okay well
i don't know if that's true but
you know maybe it is maybe it is
all right steve steve otton says noam
chomsky is the grinch who stole liberty
oh yeah you said that one yeah yeah i
saw that in the chat i was like this is
too good not to share eric benjamin
hamilton says after creating a short
film featuring yuri besmond for youtube
i instantly got a few comments calling
me a fascist makes it clear that to
communists anything different from them
is fascist as is with the anti-fascist
rampart the berlin wall so can we talk
about fascism just for a second like the
actual like poli-sci textbook version of
fascism is the merging of state and
corporate power that was mussolini's own
definition of it and if you look at like
what's happening for instance with like
social media and regulation and things
like that i mean like these are kind of
inherently like fascist arrangements
we're seeing a lot of like
fascism in mainstream america in terms
of this sort of thing and it's just
really weird to me that fascism has come
to mean basically you know anything that
the left doesn't like
we actually have yeah
quiet guitarist fan says by the way i
never read the book i'm assuming he's
talking about dune and i actually
understood it from beginning to end it's
really not that hard dude it's hilarious
how easy it is to understand if you just
pay attention once again mcu theme parks
i don't think marvel movies are
masterpieces i think they're popcorn
flicks i thought dune
uh should i can i spoil the movie that's
been remade from the 80s i don't think
so right like i can okay spoilers
all right so
here's a here's the first complaint that
someone said to me after we left was
like wait a minute that whole scene
where he's talking to idaho and he's
like i want to go with you he's like you
can't and then he has another scene
where he's like dad i want to go and you
can't and then he goes anyway and it's
kind of glossed over
like what was the point of that scene
why you know so so here was my
experience the cinematography was
fantastic the music was fantastic it was
beautifully made
but you had to know the story to enjoy
it
if you if so
like i'm sitting there with with with
you know my girlfriend and we're talking
about it and she's like did i miss
something like what is what what's the
word they're saying what's the name of
the houses like why is this one bad why
did they change the why did they do this
and i'm like people keep saying you you
just can't handle because they're trying
to cram too much in it once and i'm like
didn't cram anything in
we were confused halfway through as to
what was going on and it's because it
was so slow and drawn out that it was
just like look if you want to see part
one of an art film i got no problem with
that i just don't like it and so i'll
complain about it not want to see it
just like i thought you know uh captain
marvel was bad but there are a ton of
movies that don't have action that i
think are fantastic it's absurd people
are like their immediate responses like
jim just wants action movies like
superheroes and i'm like that's not true
i didn't see it but if you're gonna do
dune you got to give the main guy his
power within 20 minutes and then get him
off the planet within 20 minutes 25
minutes and then make it pure action
from there i mean that's
i watched a really really great video
broke down why guardians of the galaxy
people rated highly and why suicide
squad was rated poorly and they talk
about time and they were like
suicide squad tried using flashbacks to
introduce plot lines and characters and
it was really confusing for the audience
and boring
and so you don't actually get the actual
story you're trying to understand until
you're an hour in whereas guardians of
the galaxy introduces it immediately in
the intro
you know star-lord's getting the and i'm
using a marvel film i'm trying to use a
youtube example of like a breakdown
between what works and what doesn't
but i think the issue i had with uh with
dune
was that they're trying to make more
than one movie
if they just made it one movie
simple action yeah andre pointed out you
have the giant sand worm in the
beginning trying to destroy a fleeing
ship you got to show the worm i mean
that's the biggest part of the whole
series is the worms the sand worms i
read i was reading online that they were
like
the problem with the movie adaptations
the original on this one is that they're
trying to make a book which works into a
movie that doesn't
someone commented on reddit they were
like it should have opened with sand
worm so you understood the
dune the importance of the spice the
danger the worm instead it was a very
slow beginning that was kind of
confusing and the voice and you know
it's like
i haven't seen the movie but the book
and the the whole the lore and
everything that goes into the series of
dune books are known for being complex i
mean and that's what people enjoy about
the books and i can totally see where
that doesn't translate easily it
certainly didn't translate easily for
david lynch no his his inner monologue
stuff was terrible yeah translate to
movies that was confusing i tried
watching it
look movies are different mediums and
people who are fans of the book tend to
be super fans of the movie but when i
ask like just look at some of the
questions that non-fans had about
watching the movie if the movie's not
for people who have not read the book
then by all means it's not for me and
i'm then enjoy your movie i got no
problem
but
you know the way it was explained to me
was
imagine star this is what someone said
if you like star wars a new hope and you
want to watch a two-hour and 40-minute
movie that's just luke in the desert and
it ends with him finally meeting han
solo that's that's due in the movie oh
jeez yeah
but that's basically what it was
you know these days are going to be the
hero he's not threat it's the hero's
journey but he's not thrust into
adventure until the movie's over yeah
and so you're like
i didn't get that far i've heard a ton
of ecstatic things but all from people
that were like sci-fi super fans fans of
the book i'll i will say i will tell you
people don't want to hear it
we went to a theater
uh we went to the frederick theater
there was probably nine people in the
theater and it was five five were us
and i noticed other people sleeping
after after an hour and 20 or so minutes
i was just like
i'll just read what happened i'll just
i'll just read i'd rather just read this
i can't watch this it's so slow and
drawn out and i look over my girlfriend
sleeping
and then i'm like hey you want to leave
she's like yeah and then i get up i'm
like luke we're leaving he's like all
right and then we went got we got
hibachi it was great did you what were
your feelings on the stuff that you did
see i i'm not much of a film critic i
don't have much to say about this to be
honest with you he's scared to offend
the masses i don't care to offend anyone
it was just like that's a long movie
it's two hours and 40 minutes it's a lot
to sit through and i was like i'll just
watch it later so if i'm already like
i wasn't in it i wasn't enthralled by it
i was just like i'll just watch it later
at home uh because it was available so
that that tells me that i wasn't you
know entertained by i would i was super
excited for it because we watched the
original i can't i can't i can't tell
you what happened in it because it was
so slow and then a lot like we played it
downstairs a few months ago but it was
just like eventually became on in the
background
and so then when they were like they're
redoing it i was like they're gonna do
it right this time they're not gonna do
the inner monologue thing they're gonna
speed up the story i hear the story's
really good i'm excited for it and then
it was just like i started watching and
i was like wow damn there's a made for
tv version of it with william hurt that
was actually better than the david lynch
one i don't remember if it would
consider it was good at this point i
don't know there was a made for tv one
yeah william hurt check it out if you
like
um
wasn't there something like in the early
1970s they were going to attempt to make
it and like solve it or dolly was
involved or something crazy wow yeah it
was an art film version of it that never
they couldn't decide they want it to be
like star wars but then the director
wanted to be kind of an art film so it
never got made oh
let's uh let's move on we got daniel
ness he says pretty sure i've never
heard someone's doctor say due to your
allergies and other medical issues you
shouldn't stop at red lights i'm also
pretty sure any spiritual belief that
has something against red lights
wouldn't be driving
good points
all right let's see
roberto lara says the reason luke was on
fire somewhere in texas alex jones
looked up the night sky smiled raised
his finger and shot a bolt of freedom
lightning and yelled let the frogs be
frogs
that's probably it i i did feel like
there was fire in my veins oh that's
that's weird i i didn't think it was
relevant to the story but before we
walked in the building luke did get
struck by a powerful blast of green
lightning oh okay that's what that was
that's what that was i just thought it
was a puddle but
then all of a sudden he was glowing and
his hair was it was floating and he was
levitating into the building puddle full
of leeched estrogen that is making the
frogs
all right let's see
chris blank production says did you see
project veritas's new video the new
jersey governor has been saying no
mandates to get reelected while planning
to enact mandates after he's elected
that's why we left new jersey
i'm finding this uh it's legal to beat
your wife on the courthouse law is not
real it's a south carolina thing and
this other website it says it's all uh
parody yeah fake news
all right let's see
scott gross says i wonder what people
would think if they knew that paul
atreides goes on to kill entire
planetary populations to rid the galaxy
of resistance to his rule as the new
emperor
spoiler alert i don't know i don't
remember i don't want to confirm spoiler
it's like an old book and the movie
doesn't even have that in it so
paula tradies was was pretty cool i
don't remember what's the thing he's
called the quizzy tatarak
exactly you should know it should be
simplified for a common person to know
and walk away and be like he was the
jedi rather than called the quasi-tatara
that's fine they can call it the
quasi-cataract the problem i have in the
movie was that
it was just like glossed over really he
was the bene jesuit i don't remember to
yeah right i guess no i mean yeah i'm
not i'm dismissing the concept of this
it was a good book i would highly
recommend the book if you like it look
it's i think star wars
my understanding that star wars
basically ripped off dude is that true
he was heavily inspired by it i know
yeah
star wars ripped off a lot of things
right you know but
think about how star wars a new hope did
such a good job explaining everything
yeah like the force the jedi the clone
wars how these things are introduced a
new hope is a great movie it was a
samurai it wasn't they rip off a samurai
movie yeah kurosawa film the hidden
fortress uh you know very strong
influence on that yeah
but there were a whole bunch of other
things you know plus all the mythology i
mean there are like old celtic legends
about guys with flaming swords and stuff
that like you know track
uh star wars very closely and there's
all these things that were clearly you
know it was a case of you know genius
deals i think but you know also the
thing with star wars is always just so
weird because
clearly lucas had some sort of outside
influences on the set and stuff that
were you know tempering his worst
impulses you know so they didn't do you
know nine hours about trade routes or
whatever happened in the you know the
trilogy i've been trying to forget ever
since oh gosh
jar jar and dooku like duke dookie do
count dookie yeah that was just awful
terrible names but you know what i like
about the prequels is that they're like
bad movies that are funny bad you know
what i mean
i ripped my heart out i don't know and
the sequels are so much worse
all right all right
cyridin says w uh washington state is
already building isolation quarantine
camps and facilities just thought you
should know is that true we get a fact
check on that dk6 says dexter holland is
a pioneer in mrna research his
dissertation was on using mrna for hiv
treatments of course he's provex yes but
i think that was micro rna research not
messenger rna research it could be wrong
i don't know a whole lot about it yeah i
know he is like a phd in molecular
biology or something which is kind of
crazy i think 2017. punk rocker or
whatever but yeah
yeah you know he also owns a hot sauce
company yup king county was it gringo
bandito i think it's called yeah looks
like transaction they join over there
king county washington looks like it's
building isolation quarantine facility
according to their weapons bishop cruz
says the offspring song self-esteem is
all about weak men letting horrible
women take advantage of them might as
well be sung by the prototypical male
feminist come out and play was also
prescient
i listened that song a hundred times
yeah i was taking it off the radio i was
told come out and play when i was little
was racist
you got to keep them separated
i mean they were from la and like the
gang situation at the time was you know
legit out of control
so i i assume they kind of knew what
they were speaking about yeah
i don't actually think it was racist
that's good you know anyway domenic uh
dominic falcone says dinosaur junior is
my favorite band just happy to hear it
mentioned on one of my favorite shows
hey there you go i'm a massive jamascus
dinosaur junior fan
what's that what's that one song um
like that really popular song they had
uh
the the one kind of song they got that
was sort of popular was called feel the
pain yes feel the pain yup
i know that one that's about it
all right let's see
we'll grab something down here
anonymous anonymous says on the topic of
music pink floyd's 1977 animals is a
great album i think it speaks measures
for the times we're in
so they the original dune trailer was
tracked to that um you know pink floyd
cover whatever it was really awesome
but as i seem to recall and maybe i'm
miss remembering this but um when i
mentioned that early 1970s dune attempt
with salvador dali i think pink floyd
might also have been
involved in that at one point or
something
um but you know either way um yes
pink floyd and dune seem to track up
nicely
all right let's see
yeah dune with a mick jagger and
salvador dali 1970s okay my name is mick
jagger i guess
in the cash runner 55 says valuetainment
podcast had a facebook moderator on and
it was difficult to watch you should
have one or both on
i mean ian was a social media moderator
and he tells horrifying stories about
things we can't talk about i would love
to have a facebook moderator in here to
get their perspective
all right let's see
kin
confucianis is that what it says who do
you think has killed more dogs the fbi
or fouchy would anyone care if the dogs
were
were placed back into nursing retirement
homes
oh jeez
fed tea says pro tip eat healthy
exercise plan for your health 50 60
years out if we all participated in this
we wouldn't need as much animal testing
and better protections from coven this
is what i wanted to bring up earlier i i
want to refocus the conversation onto
how exciting it is to stay healthy i
think that people get excited about
sickness and not like they get terrified
which is a form of excitement and but
really it's exciting to stay alive and
stay healthy i know there's no end to it
so it's not like
there's not this final excitement point
that you're looking at but man is it fun
to feel good or all the things that you
can do that are exciting when you're
healthy
all right slick black cadillac says tim
the scene calling for baldwin to point
the revolver at the camera means the gun
must appear loaded to moviegoers i
believe this fact is pivotal to the
chain of events also i see luke i
exacerbate okay well um when it comes to
pointing a gun at the camera
wouldn't that require very specific set
of
safety protocols to point a gun at a
camera that appears loaded
i would like to not see i would see the
cinematographer not standing behind the
camera in line of fire not supposed to
do that yeah like we have cameras here
that are remote controlled
accidents happened on the set before and
uh that's how they happen it's criminal
i think it's criminal i don't know if
that means you go to jail for it i think
a jury can figure that out but
it's criminal
it's
definitely a degree of negligence that
merits lawn
investigation uh been a very serious one
about you know criminal charges for sure
all right let's see
raven knight says there was a sci-fi
channel mini-series of dune that was
great
i bet that's the one with william hurt
that might be cool it really actually
was i came off the david lynch one so
anything was good for me at that point
but
i remember not being horrible and
william hurt was awesome
he played the dad jacob emanuel says hey
tim i live in illinois not crap cargo
but my company tried to mandate the shot
we all walked out now they have allowed
us to remove masks and no shots last
election we voted to be separated from
crapkago love the show wow
i hear all these stories where people
are like my boss mandated the vaccine
and we said no and then they changed
their minds
isn't amazing how unionization works
isn't it funny that the left is mocking
these people when they're enacting
collective bargaining power
i love it
well it cuts both ways i mean the
schools were also shut for 18 months
unnecessarily because of unions too but
it is true that i do think that in our
current situation people need to think a
lot more about collective action and
conservatives need to get a lot more
comfortable with it too
all right
mavis says dune was created by a guy
that only read the wikipedia page and
based his base the movie off of that
i'm going to call fake news on that one
i think he's just making a joke yeah
darkseid 66 says everyone is asking why
alex had a loaded gun i want to know why
he was pointing any gun at the
cinematographer and the director i
wonder how often that happens in movies
because you get the pointing at the
camera shot which probably looks amazing
on film but how often are they standing
there i would like to know what is the
rationale for ever having a live round
on a movie set ever for any reason yeah
we but we went over this on the show
last week and like
i mean
it's becomes conspiratorial at that
point yeah
i suppose the uh the there's there's uh
cartridges that have no powder in it
it's just the bullet so it looks real
and they use those for appearance right
and then there are blanks
but
i don't know somebody somebody put a
bullet in that and it's alec baldwin's
fault he was handed a real gun
and the left is desperate to say
somebody doesn't know what it's like to
be on set it's like you're talking about
i lived in i lived in hollywood i had a
bunch of friends who worked i was in a
stupid tv show once it's not like i was
around big movie sets but i've been
around them and it's insane to think
that that's an excuse for being handed a
loaded weapon and bingo but i didn't
know it was loaded
i fired a blank once out of a m1 garand
but not at any one just out into the
woods
i got in the car i was told to drive at
full speed towards these people and they
said don't worry it would be fine but
the but then i hit them and they died
it's like what happened why did you do
that
yeah maybe you should check you should
be careful
all right let's see
says luke t-shirt saying i'm with dave
using one script like i'm with hillary
type another with a trump type text
interesting maybe um i'll talk to my
designer see what they think i'm with
dave my friends if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and go to timcast.com become a member
have a members only segment coming up
around 11 or so p.m but we also have a
massive library of members only content
you can watch all of the alex jones
stuff and steve bannon and uh just a
bunch of jack basobic and the frequent
guests we have definitely check that out
sheamus all that good fun stuff so
become a member and you can follow this
show at tim castoral everywhere you can
follow me personally at tim cast mark
you want to shout anything out
uh no other than uh
i got a book out
it's behind me it's great you got
twitter or something oh yeah i am at
heminator and twitter
that's a nice name i like that one so i
said it was pretty cool i signed up for
twitter like 10 years ago with my stupid
college nickname because i was like this
won't be of any professional use
whatsoever right of course like i'm now
cursing that it is literally destroying
the entire journalism ministry but
that's how i ended up with that hamilton
i'm just going to call you that from now
on uh and i released two videos today
one on youtube.com forward slash we are
change about janet yellen's crazy plans
for you and
another one very important one on
lukeuncensored.com that i can't tell you
about
i wanna i'm ian crossland and i another
huge shout out to the event on saturday
night at long shot in west virginia tim
thanks for putting it on man yeah and we
got some behind-the-scenes footage uh
there's see uh episode of cass castle up
today check it out on youtube if you
want to see like the lead up to it
everybody getting ready doing sound
checks really awesome
the cartoon for that was amazing yeah i
think he's getting better i think we
have the members on the event
four members on timecast.com i don't
know if it's uploaded yet yeah it may
not be
the member is only i can just i saw a
thumbnail for it for sure that's
exciting yeah is there a lot of footage
from that night and you guys that came
out you are incredible i met so many
people
thank you so much i got this
a voodoo doll this is ian crossland
voodoo bobblehead be nice to it
i don't think it's up yet but we'll try
and get it up as soon as possible
but like the comedy the energy the
people the just interactions it was it
was powerful ryan long was incredible
and we could have like had a
huger venue but but i think even keeping
it this small having that kind of like
those kind of real small intimate
conversations with individuals
one-on-one was was pretty important the
plan is we're going to do the exact same
thing
in miami nice i like it i love that
sound
yeah you know it's because i was talking
about you mean free america that's right
i was talking to ryan long and he was
mentioning like fort lauderdale in the
miami area and i was like you know i've
been trying to get luke forever
i've been screaming about florida
forever but but um someone else brought
up the anti-communist movement there
because of all of the expats is massive
and they absolutely would love a freedom
oriented kind of event and so
you know we were thinking about doing
the same thing and then having it be
if we do a bigger venue we can have an
area for members like we did but then
we'd also sell tickets to the public for
like upper seating and stuff yeah hard
rock cafe i mean there's a reason i stay
there half the year i love it down there
the energy down there is huge and it's
one of the few places that is actually
free
yeah that's funny you use the word
energy this is exactly how i describe it
i had to go to a wedding down in tampa a
month or two ago and it was just
shocking it was like it was like going
to an entirely different country in
terms of people are alive
there's like like things are happening
in the state people are like optimistic
um and in addition to the fact it didn't
have any of the insane code protocols uh
it just it was you know there's no
negativity there's no one harping and
like being mad at you for not wearing a
mask none of that well we'll uh we'll
we'll get on that oh and literally yeah
thank you guys for tuning in thank you
all who came to the event i was watching
ian he went hard for like seven hours i
was like how is he doing this i kept
needing to step outside ian like didn't
even come up for air it was ridiculous i
was like this man i trained for 20 years
to do this dude yes he is
a people person i love it very much so
hopefully we can do more like that he
got on stage and he looked at everyone
and said i have been training for 40
years for this moment today and then he
put the guitar and everyone was like
yeah
that was good that's what happens all
right everybody we will see you all over
at timcast.com thanks for hanging out
bye guys
you